in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuing to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a public
hearing on bills referred to the
committee and scheduled in the house
calendar for today and exec session may
be held on any bills referred to the
committee no not going to happen please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporar asly in this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporar usly during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporarily listen and if necessary
participate in the meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court web system website the
notice on this meeting compiles complies
with house rules in uh RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email HCS ledge. state. n.
Us in the event of the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled please note
that all the votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote and let's start the meeting by
taking a roll call ATT
when each member states their presence
please also State whether there's anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required on the right to no
law okay Keith you're
on all right ready for the roll yes
please representative John Hunt I am
here and I am
alone representative John pusk uh I am
here upstairs in my house my wife is
downstairs and will not be coming up
representative Jason
Osborne Representative Keith Ammon
that's me present and
alone representative Max
Abramson oh
alone representative Bonnie ham alone
I'm
here representative Joseph
dama here and alone
representative Jeffrey
gon present and
alone representative Don
Johnson here and alone for a
change representative Paul
Terry here I'm alone in the room uh my
wife may be in and out she is joint
owner of the house and she can go
wherever she
wants all
right representative Christy Bartlett
I am in my home and I'm alone in the
room all right representative Richard
Abel I am at home and I am the only one
in in the room uh at
present representative Chris
Herbert they mute muted Rich I'm mute
Chris
uh home um and my wife is in another
office so
okay representative Connie van hton
present
alone representative Tina Fargo I'm
present and
alone representative Joyce
Weston I'm home and I'm
alone representative Jane bellu
I'm home and I am not alone but I'm
alone in this
room all right representative Anita
burrow I am I am present uh my husband
is in the
home
okay representative Chris
melier um I am home and I am
alone all right that's the role Mr chair
all right thank you very
much uh okay we'll open up the public
hearing on House Bill 162 and hear from
the prime sponsor representative pusc
good morning representative pusc good
morning Mr chair good morning ladies and
gentlemen of the Commerce Committee for
the record uh representative John pusk
Rockingham 6 which is Derry New
Hampshire uh I take pleasure in
presenting House Bill 162 permitting
tastings by liquor manufacturers at
farmers markets this is nothing nothing
more than uh
adding uh the tasting of distilled
spirits to the bill which we've
processed through twice before with wine
tastings and beer
tastings um I am aware that there is
another bill on the Senate on excuse me
across the wall that is basically the
same
thing um and that basically is about it
this uh bill allows a 1 half ounce
sample per label per person for any
question which is a distilled
Spirit um and that is
basically um it in a
nutshell so uh Pam I'm not sure where
that's coming from because everybody
else is pretty well muted but right I lo
did the same thing I see everybody muted
I I don't know either but I'll keep an
eye out just worry whether we're getting
our wires crossed in the committee room
with some other committee but all right
so we do have questions uh and we have
representative Ben hton
first thank you Mr chair and good
morning representative pusk um I have a
question I'm looking at the at the bill
at the moment and I'll read you a
sentence that is of concern to me it's
the very last sentence of the bill
proper it says such prod project
products I'm sorry such products may be
sold at retail at a farmer's market in
the original containers that doesn't
sound like a sample to me well that is
well that's not the sample that is like
uh the other manufacturers which sell
bottles of wine cans or bottles of beer
and they will have bottles of their
product which they can sell that is not
a sample the sample is basically on on
any of these uh alcoholic products
is to uh provide some
information to the possible consumer on
what the taste of the product
is uh if you can have sales of wine
sales of beer you should also be able to
have sales of distilled
Spirits okay further question yes follow
up if I may please um maybe it's just
the wording and and do get hung up on
Words and don't apologize for that
because of who I am in my background but
it does sound as though that does deal
with samples I don't know if anyone else
sees it that way actually in the
previous sentence it does say they can
charge for
samples it says may offer samples as
provided but then when it says products
sold at retail at a farmer's market in
the original containers that doesn't
sound like a sample to me that sounds
like a market oh that's correct no it's
when they're going to bring they're
going to bring their regular product
with them and that they're going to sell
sample they're going to open a bottle or
whatever sell the samples or give away
the sample but then if the uh person
who's at the farmers's market would like
to take one home they uh the old the old
days well not for distill but the old
days with wine they used to have to go
to the liquor store to get it and we had
gen changed the policy that um yes they
can
bring um whether it's beer and wine now
and this this will add distilled Liquors
they can bring a product with them and
sell it at the farmers market so the the
term retail may be a little confusing
but it's it implied to mean is that no
you wholesale you got to go through the
you got to go through the Liquor
Commission but that you can sell the
product so for the question thank you no
I at the risk of of just being a little
bit um specific here it does say and I
agree with what you're saying and I
agree that that's the intent I don't
have a problem with that but the
previous sentence says may offer samples
and then it goes on to say such products
I suggest that there might be some
wording that be would be looked at there
because I do understand the intent of
the bill and I I was part of the
commission from which this arose so um
just to just to throw that out I do
believe it's ambiguous and that's just
me so you're saying such products so you
wouldn't say such uh distilled liquor
rather than saying probably yeah that
would probably be a better wording if if
anyone agrees with me or disagrees with
me I'll be happy to um simply back out
of this conversation and let it continue
without me thank you very much okay okay
you can put your hand down and
representative Bartlett you were next
but I
know sorry I lowered my hand okay great
uh next is uh representative
Herbert I'm M um when you when you say a
retail um my question is uh um um is
when you say sell at retail is the uh is
the State Liquor Commission going to be
able to uh uh gain a a a income as when
they sell there
correct yes okay thank
you and uh representative
peros yes thank you for taking my
question um just just a quick one um
under current law would the farmers
markets be required to take
from people to ensure that they're of
legal age particularly I'm more
concerned about the takeaways than the
the small samples but will they be
taking ID so
uh yes go ahead John typically yes I I I
am on the board of directors of the
Dairy Farmers Market and we have beer
and wine tastings at our markets and
yes the answer is unequivocally yes
excellent if you go in the whole area is
roped off special you can't even go in
the area unless you're like a kid that
goes with their parents and the IDS are
check perfect thank you okay
representative
Fargo um yes thank you Mr chair um I
think that this is a good idea to
promote local wineries and distilleries
and things like that I think that's
really nice but I don't see anything in
the Bild that re stricks it to made in
New Hampshire so um any does that mean
that any wine
or uh manufacturer from anywhere in the
country or anywhere at all could come
and um sell their liquor beer or wine at
a farmers's
market interesting uh there will the
answer is no the answer is no the the
the secret is that it says liquor
manufacturer but it doesn't restrict it
to New Hamp I'm that's restricted you
don't have out ofate manufacturers
they're manufactured outstate but they
have a different kind of
license okay thank you also um we're
going to have testimony from one of our
folks from The Liquor Commission so if
you want to bring that question up I'm
quite sure uh M Mo will be very happy to
answer that question
okay we all said everybody said okay
Aiden you're
on good morning uh committee members can
you hear me okay we can hear you great
great thank you very much good morning
Mr chairman and committee members nice
to see you this year virtually um I
wanted to uh uh rep answer
representative Fargo's um question and
and also bring to you uh bring to you
your attention that at the same time
that you're taking up this bill Senate
Bill 18 is working its way uh through
the system which has uh an an exactly uh
similar purpose for allowing uh tastings
uh of uh liquor at farmers markets um
one of the things that I think is worth
noting is that farmers markets have a
great deal of control at the local level
so um a manufacturer whether it's beer
or wine or Spirits in this case would
have to go to the local community and uh
apply for and get local approval under
the terms of which uh the tap tastings
and samplings were to take place uh so
that that is always part of the
process the uh concern about having um
instate manufacturers was actually
raised in the
Senate and as a part of that the bill
was amended there to include language
that says a liquor manufacturer that
produces less than 10,000
bottles during their licensing Year and
that operates and produces liquor solely
within the state may transport its
products to farmers markets and may
offer samples as provided in this
paragraph uh I think the commission felt
very comfortable with that and uh and to
uh support the original intent which is
to allow New Hampshire
manufacturers um the opportunity uh to
sample their products uh and also uh
preclude go ahead was that you Aiden
um that's the chairman calling me um I
think he doesn't like what I said I
text yes so uh we would we would
encourage uh that if if the Senate Bill
18 makes its way that there' be possibly
some
reconciliation in the language um that
would limit the participants to those
who produce less than a certain
quantity and who are limited to being
New Hampshire producers uh as well I'm
not sure if that's answered your
question representative Fargo but I'm
happy to answer any questions from from
the
committee okay do you have anything else
you want to on your testimony or you
just here to uh that's that's it
okay uh so John you can't ask a
question okay represent able you may
inquire uh yes I I wanted to uh
ask uh whether uh liquor
uh
manufacturers under under this bill um
are um are whether there's um
correspondence are are are the
arrangements the same for uh for other
beverages that uh The Liquor Commission
oversees in other words we I didn't want
to see us have a bill that where we had
different rules for different categories
are the CATE are they all treated
equivalently thank you for your question
representative AEL uh the the bill seeks
to amend the um provision that deals
with tastings for wine and beverages so
uh it would be consistent with with what
exists uh for the other two
areas yeah if you look at the sentence
um you'll see it's just adding on to the
sentence
or okay representative Fargo uh thank
you thank you Mr chairman um could you
tell me what that Senate bill number is
again it would be Senate Bill 18 18
thank you Aiden you're
welcome and representative MCL um Mr
Moore uh do you have any idea how many
uh distillers there are in New Hampshire
that's number one uh number two would it
if there's not that many would it maybe
make sense to include that same
limitation on bottles but uh include
neighboring states so that would include
Vermont Maine and
Massachusetts
um we I can't tell you ex the exact
number I can get back to you with that
number representative for the exact
number of distillers in New Hampshire uh
I'm I'm not
sure um that the farmers market the
intent of the farmers market is to
promote products from outside of the
state
um and I think that's uh representative
pusk um and uh you know was part of the
and representative van hton were part of
the commission on what we call I guess
alcohol tourism and um the I believe the
intent of the bill is to promote New
Hampshire manufacturers um versus
manufacturers from outside of the state
um so I I I think leaving it the way it
is in the sense of who would be eligible
to participate um is is consistent with
other uh aspects of this uh legislation
uh so for example if you were going to
allow it for out ofate then you'd need
to go back and change it for wine you
need to go back to change it for beer
and and that would uh create probably
quite a conundrum for the local
communities who are trying to uh manage
this
okay any other
questions uh see none we thank you very
much for your testimony and I'm going to
leave you up but uh just please mute so
that when you talk to the
chairman I'll be muting now sir and
making that call I'm Gonna Leave You on
here because you g obviously testify
again okay and last up is uh Jim demur
who is uh representing spirits and L
spirits is in support of the bill uh
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
committee members uh for the record my
name is James deur and today I am
representing the New Hampshire Wine and
Spirits Brokers Association which is the
larger brokers who
Market uh distilled spirits and wine to
the New Hampshire Liquor Commission and
while this bill applies to small instate
distilleries uh we are in support of the
version that uh has been worked on in
the Senate and I wanted to make you
aware that Senate Bill 18 um my
recollection from the work session that
took place in the Senate Commerce
Committee is that all of the
stakeholders were supportive of the
changes and that bill has actually
passed the Senate a week and a half ago
and is on its way to the house um at
crossover so it's already passed uh the
Senate
um and as you've heard that bill made a
couple of additional safeguards that
aren't in the house version that
accomplishes the goals of the small
local distilleries of giving them the
opportunity to do wine tastings just
like local breweries and wineries can do
at farmers markets and to sell their
product um at those uh farmers markets
and um the changes had as I mentioned I
think had the support of all the
stakeholders the bill um I really think
the bill that's before you today isn't
necessary because Senate Bill 18 um has
been amended and it's on its way to you
so my recommendation would be to itl
House Bill 162 and support Senate Bill
118 when it comes over from the
Senate
okay I guess you're you're neutral I see
that now I read the wrong column okay uh
any questions of Mr
deur okay seeing none we thank you very
much for your
testimony uh and is there anybody who is
attending with who uh would like to
speak
hands getting
raised
so um I'll close the public hearing and
uh so uh Pam sent you guys all the the
blue sheet so you can see it if you want
to print it U I recommend uh reducing
your printer to tell it to reduce to 80%
and that way you can get everything on
the page and um you can see that sort 18
support two or neutral one oppos and I
believe that's fry from new Futures I
suppose but did not want to
testify okay with that I will close the
public hearing on House Bill
162 so the next one's at 9:30 okay so we
have six
minutes freshen your coffee
um
okay chairman
hunt yes
sorry yes cor the next two the next two
bills seem to me to be related they are
very much related and I'm just I'm a
little uh I
just I mean one is talks to relative to
food and cigar shops the other one
relative to on prom on premises cigar
beverage and liquor
licenses so it it sounds to me as though
number one one of them wants to be able
to uh sell liquor and then the other one
wants to be able to also sell
food so I I don't understand seem to be
a that's why we have a public hearing so
you can a conflict of purposes there two
bills two different things
but business um I mean you could say
that uh and I know that we did in the
past where we try to do piggyback
hearings you know when um uh and I I
find it sometimes confusing to do that
piggyback thing and try to do things at
the same time I realized it was supposed
to be a timesaver but I'm not sure it is
um but I think it's more if you have the
same people were testifying both bills
then then you say make you only have to
get up and say it once but uh in this
case um one one is very simple and very
small and and um targeted on an issue
and the other one opens up a uh U to be
frank open up a can of worms so so
that's why I felt that they should have
separate public
hearings but we'll see that's why we
have
hearings
the next
one
okay all right so Jim I'm G to remove
[Music]
you
and I'm going to
upgrade cures
and
uh and so cage just stay muted
thanks
be
just so you know I think that sound that
you may be hearing is the the um air
system in the committee room just turned
off but they kind of cycle on and off a
little bit and they do sound like a you
know crowd noise or something a roar of
a crowd for a little while but
that it's gone now so I'll stop talking
actually I think it's their the new Air
Purifiers in the room too because we
were John and I were in
there they uh they cycled on and off
differently than the air system did
too right right the little it's a it's a
new sound for us so and if you haven't
been in the
room you might not know what it is is is
there any way we can turn off the
microphone in the committee room because
you're right it's
distracting we could but the only way to
turn it back on is to run down there and
do it and and I I know nobody's in the
room right now but somebody could appear
so it's from our
committee from your committee I mean I
know that um representative Osborne came
in for the exec last
time so I don't think it'll If it
creates a big problem you know I can I
can U mute it but I'd prefer to to leave
it as is because I think most of the
time it's quiet
okay
Mr chair if you're trying to talk to us
you're
muted so there's some black thing
sitting on the chair in the back of the
room there because at first I thought
maybe there was somebody there turned
sideways but I guess there's did you
leave a jack your jacket on the chair
there John nope I have everything with
me um maybe that's just turned sideways
there's a large desktop computer there
they put in some desktop computers that
might be what you're
seeing Oh okay I'm not sure Del is a
screen it could be a screen yeah okay
all right it's 9:30 we'll open up the
public Hearing in House Bill
171 and hear from the prime sponsor
representative pusk good morning again
represent pus good morning again Mr
chair and ladies and gentlemen uh my
esteemed colleague on the Commerce
Committee I am here to present House
Bill
17 relative to food in cigar shops it's
very simple
actually it
removes
uh excuse me it it says quote does not
allow cigarette smoking
or service and what does it removes
service
it replaces it with the sale of food
which means if you go to a cigar shop uh
they may have snacks on the counter that
you may partake in for zero
cost therefore they are providing but
not selling and that's all this does and
I think you'll agree with me that if
you're going to be going to a cigar St
store or shop which I don't do
personally but if you do I know folks
that do they have
uh things there that you can
try and you have your cigar and as long
as you have something in your stomach
when if you are drinking a beverage it
makes it better for that beverage to be
uh assimilated into your body rather
than have nothing as a snack so that's
basically all all it is it changes one
word from
service to sale and prohibits the sale
of
food and with that I rest my
testimony okay are there any questions
from the committee
members
okay uh seeing none uh this time we'll
do a little bit differently so uh will
Curtis uh Barry would like to testify to
the
bill good morning good morning good
morning thank you Mr chair members of
the committee uh my name is Curtis Barry
here this morning uh on behalf of the
New Hampshire cigar
Association um in support of the bill
and as representer pusk mentioned it's a
very simple change uh I hope you all
received either by US mail or email um
the documents I sent with the backup
with the with the statute which I think
is important to get the full context of
this so when um the statute was
originally passed in order to make sure
that a cigar bar did not become a
full-blown
restaurant uh they put a Prohibition in
among other things that you could not
serve food and what we've discovered is
serving food is interpreted to mean even
as representative Tusk said uh offering
snacks on on the bar um the traditional
bar snacks so what we propos to do um as
a Senate Bill last year did and
unfortunately got hung up in the
suspension of the legislature is uh
change one word from service to sale so
now the prohibition would be on the sale
of food we could serve food which means
the cigar bar is allowed to provide a
snack on the bar it's really that simple
um there was no opposition last year uh
I I'm not aware of any POS opposition
this year um and just for background I'm
aware uh Mr chair I think there are
about a dozen and a half Cigar Bar
licenses in the state currently uh
roughly a third of them I think are
members of our association and we
represent about 13 locations among uh
five owners uh of the uh cigar shops
some of them have a cigar B light in
them and some do not uh it's really
folks that that simple I'm happy to
answer questions to the best of my
ability um but also Mr chair um
participating in the the committee
meeting is Kurt Kendall one of the the
license owners he's got uh twins smoke
shop down in London Dairy so any
questions that I'm unable to answer um
he may be able to as well okay well I
would just yeah let Kurt know to raise
your hand if you would like to speak at
some point I think we're pretty
straightforward here here I only have
one other person thank you Curtis any
questions from the committee members for
Curtis uh we do uh represent
mcer uh yes uh Mr bar what is a snack I
mean a snack could be anything from a
pretzel to a hamburger a slider sure um
you know it that subject has come up in
the past and I appreciate the question
um if we go down the road of trying to
Define what they're going to provide uh
it gets to be awfully difficult the
where you draw a line I would suggest
that if they're not selling a product
right they're not making any money
they're providing it free they're really
not going to offer something terribly
substantial it's a our philosophy is we
want to provide something for the
stomachs of folks that are um partaking
in adult beverages it's it's really that
simple great thank you uh representative
ham
thank thank you Mr chairman um I'm I
just wondered I thought that in order to
serve alcoholic beverages um you needed
to um serve food and so I'm just curious
how how the cigar bar can be serving
alcoholic beverages without serving a
meal or substantial food right well
those licenses are the different license
types within the Li statutes this
license type which uh is in the statute
that I sent around 178
20a uh creates a license type that does
not require food sale uh it does require
that uh if you look at it it's 2A in
that statute uh that the location
generates 60% of or more of its
quarterly gross revenue from the sale of
cigar related products so it's it's
similar in that it requires a threshold
they can't just be
alcohol and oh by the way sell a cigar
here or there um the primary purpose of
the business must be the sale of cigars
at retail um but then they're allowed
this particular license type which if I
recall correctly was around 2009 put
into statute um allows for the sale of
alcohol in a bar setting regulated with
these Provisions um which include that
the sale of the retail product 60% or
more um does not allow cigarette smoking
and some of the other Provisions that
you see in the
statute thank you all set thank you for
the
question yes we'll be talking about that
food requirement again and other
bills okay any other questions
from many members okay I assume Bonnie
your hand is still up you just didn't
put it down yet okay all right well
thank you very much Curtis thank you and
I will be moving you over and so last
but not least is uh Aiden Moore from The
Liquor Commission uh which is neutral on
the
bill gon a good morning
Aiden yeah you're you're already
unmuted I think
Aiden still chatting with the
[Laughter]
commissioner he's muted unmuted muted
unmuted I think he's having some
technical
difficulties there Aiden maybe not you
might want to have to reboot and get
back in
again
what he's
doing
okay sounds like the the machine is like
a waves it sounds like ocean waves
coming in and
out a nice way to think about it a
calming backround noise we we're all at
the beach you know I want to have too
much white news and then we'll start
falling asleep
bring your sunglasses in your
book I see um um Mark armaganian has his
hand up out in the U okay all right I
will promote him to
panelist
and okay Mark you can you can unmute
yourself and pick up where Aiden left
left
us
there he is how's that
great uh thank you first of all uh I
have Aiden on the phone right now he is
having some technical difficulties so uh
we apologize for that and I'm sure being
a long day today we'll figure it out
before uh we go too much longer but uh
um first of all for uh thank you Mr
chairman and and Comm many members um
for those of you that I haven't had the
opportunity to meet my name is Mark
armaganian I'm the chief of uh the
liquor commission's enforcement and
Licensing Division um and yes we are
neutral uh on this uh Bill also uh
Curtis uh stated very well that uh this
particular license type does not have a
food requirement unlike quite a few
others um and I Leave Myself open for
any questions uh that might have been
posed with the uh uh with the testimony
that was
given okay any other questions from the
committee yes representative Abel is
up yes than thank you so much for your
testimony it's good to see you again um
I just wanted to make sure that uh
there's no unintended
consequences uh in in this uh bill um
that the different
licensing uh costs and so forth um that
there would be nothing that would make
someone want to shift to a different
license because now they could serve
food or um I I can't see that but I I
just wanted to get your assurance that
that wasn't the case y uh thank you
representative and and you've heard me
testify that quite often that there is
always an un unintended consequence to
uh a lot of these bills um that are
coming in that have that are actually
touching some of our
rsas um and and with this one I do not
see anything unintended at the same time
this is a a license type that at some
point we probably have to look at
because we're we're seeing a lot of uh
hookah bars um that are popping or
trying to pop up uh utilizing this
license type and it's being used
improperly so um probably a conversation
for a different time but uh uh in full
disclosure no this would not I don't see
any unintended
consequences but great question thank
you okay represent Bel
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um what is the cost for a
license like this for an owner of a
cigar
bar I will get that information for and
and the only reason I say that is the
license fees have been um spoken about
quite often and I don't want to confuse
this license type fee with a fee that
were
proposing um that that's coming down the
road so um it I probably need about five
minutes to walk down the hallway here
and just make verify that I give you the
right number I just don't want yeah it's
it's not important but a followup Mr
chair there a question in uh cigar bars
do they just sell cigars yes that's it
and cigar products tobacco
products cigarettes so no cigarettes
cigars only
all right um and uh one more question
the snack thank you uh the snacks um are
they packaged because I mean I mean this
is covid times but I'm not sure if you
regulate if they're packaged or not um
the food requirement would just be that
there's uh food according to the statute
whatever the ratios of are and you're
going to hear as uh the chairman said
you're going to hear
uh food being brought up quite often
today um in this the regulatory uh body
over that would be
HHS um it wouldn't be us just because it
has to do with food all we care about is
that the standard is met not how it's
packaged okay uh representative
abenson thank you Mr Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I'm looking
at or last night I was looking at this
bill and House Bill
337 um it looks like they affect the
same line of text in the RSA I wonder if
passage of both of them could create a
conflict
yeah yeah you you can't you can't pass
both you have to choose one of the other
and then amend uh amend one of the bills
to for trying to accomplish both
gims uh
what the public policy of this what the
committee decides whether they think
it's appropriate that food be sold at a
cigar
bar or vice
versa
right okay uh Aiden you're
back you you dare good morning sir I was
getting I was getting launched into
other committees which are not nearly as
inter as this committee so I glad to be
back lattery will get you
everywhere so is there anything else you
want to share yeah no I I I was able to
hear the chief and of course he uh he
did a very nice job of stating the
issues and uh answering questions so uh
uh just to just to let the committee
know we'll be here all day for as a
resource in case there are questions
about how the law works and we'll be
happy to try to explain that great oh
yeah speak um Mark did since you did
actually speak um when you when you get
off when we get off do go online and
sign up and just so people know that you
um also that fee uh Mr chairman is
$840
840 okay so max is do you have another
question or is your hand still
up okay all right so we have anyone
else uh I don't see anybody else so I'll
ask any attendees if you would like to
say ask a question raise your
hand or speak excuse me not ask a
question
speak okay I guess I don't see any
anybody there so I'll close the public
hearing on House Bill 171 thank
you all right so the next one um I don't
see the sponsor in 337 did did the
sponsors sign up I guess I should no no
that's I gave you everything there was
to give right so uh I see that
representative Abramson is one of the
one of the co-sponsors co there it says
I see Cody blaner okay great oh good
okay right so I'm gonna promote him to
panelists of course we're a little early
now we are early so I'm not going to
technically open but I'm just just
trying to along here as my technician
Tech job here as I'm just trying to move
things along um and pull up people um
ahead of time so we don't have that lag
trying to avoid that
lag well you're so efficient you get
yourself ahead that
way I ask Pam a question while we have a
moment yes uh Pam could you send us the
blue sheets from last
week um didn't I send them last week I
don't think so
no have them as a
record um let me see if I still have
them I might
have well I I would have them so I I'll
if you don't have them I can I can send
it to them I don't think any of the
committee members got
it
NOP okay I can read generate them I I
wipe them out because you know they're
not the final sheets you know what I
sent to you there's no reason to really
for me to keep them other than if you
ask for them later um so I can recreate
them thank
you are we starting again at 10 do we
have a moment yes we do we have okay
thank
you
I think Anita was taking care of her cat
so I'm going to mute
her
I got
that
e
so uh Aiden do you mind um muting
yourself yeah so the uh the question is
going back to that first bill the
definition of liquor
manufacturer um and that and then the
Senate decid to narrow it down can that
language it it seemed really narrow
right so it sound like like you were
intentionally making sure s sagra or or
other larger uh distillers could not
participate in sampling at Farmers
Market is that what that narrowing was
about I guess he's still having trouble
how about you
mark
they're both they're
all
you still can hear me
[Music]
Aiden
e
okay so Aiden is having ongoing uh
difficulties uh so he Mark is Gonna Fill
In If he if he fails again right now
he's gonna log out and then come back in
again so that we can hopefully we can
start this right
so okay
chairman can you hear me now I can hear
you you're good Miracle of Technology
it's a
Marvel so we'll see see what happens
just don't do any don't touch anything
that's
so uh for the rest of the committee
members what he and I were discussing U
just so everybody understand U and that
is that my answer about uh being a um
liquor manufacturer is the correct
answer but that when the question I you
probably might have heard me ask was
related to sazak a larger let's say very
large Distillery um and they're really
the only one we have here in New
Hampshire is a large Distillery that we
did narrow it um so that they would not
participate um sazak is sort of um in
this in our business is sort of
controversial in the sense that um they
are a third fourth category um which but
also they are a liquor manufacturer but
they are what we um call a
rectifier uh and I'm not sure everybody
in the committee knows what a rectifier
is but rectifier is someone who
Blends so uh they s could be bringing um
Canadian whiskey down and mixing in
cinnamon and uh um jalapeno I don't know
I think it's cinnamon is what they mix
in and and make a that hot hot whatever
uh whiskey that's very popular so that
that's a rectifier we do have another
rectifier in
Salem who uh takes uh who makes lemon
cello uh but I don't know how big they
are and whether that this minum U What
legislation in terms of what is to allow
them to participate or not but that's
another story of course but I just want
to make sure everybody um understands uh
that we are narrowing it down to being
just AA a small distillery in the state
of New Hampshire
um all right it's 10 o'clock uh we'll
open up the public hearing on uh house
bill
uh
337 and here from the prime sponsor
representative beler good morning
representative
beler uh good morning uh chairman hunt
um and uh thank you uh Mr chairman and
esteem members of the committee my name
is representative Cody Banger um I am
one of the representatives from eping
New Hampshire and today I come before
you in support of HB
337 um what this Bill does is strike out
specific language in the bill excuse me
in the current
RSA and uh if you have the bill in front
of you it strikes out or service of food
uh and the reason why um I frequent um
frequently smoke um cigars
myself um hearing from consumers um and
being a consumer
myself um
while while we enjoy a nice smoke and
we'll enjoy a beverage while we're there
um the one thing that we're not allowed
to do is buy or even be served food um
this doesn't stop you from bringing food
in um but sometimes uh for example at
some some locations they're open late
you might not be around um a shop so uh
excuse me a a food um entity um so this
bill fixes that and what and and allows
that to change obviously the argument is
you know you shouldn't have food and
near smoke you know it's unhealthy you
know whatever um and that is obviously
going to be an argument that you have
either heard from the previous bill
which I'm also a co-sponsor of um and um
perhaps an argument that you may hear
over this bill um but it is but what it
does is subject the
consumer to purchase the product whether
that be a cigar and say chips and salsa
or mozzarella sticks or something to
that effect should they choose um the
number one thing that I want to point
out and again this may be an argument
that be made is that this does not turn
a cigar bar into a restaurant um just
putting that out there you are still
required to sell 60% of your sales with
cigar supplies whether that these cigars
themselves whether that be um again
cigar supplies humidor over the packs
lighters Etc which is already outlined
in the RSA um this just allows um cigar
bars uh if should they choose to do this
obviously they don't have to if they
don't want to sell or provide right
because the the previous bill doesn't
exactly say that they have to uh excuse
me they they wouldn't be able to sell um
this allows both to happen should the
establishment choose to do so um and
with that I will be more than happy to
take any
questions okay uh we do uh
representative Fargo has a question yes
thank you Mr chairman um representative
Bellinger the the analysis says that um
the bill allows scy bars to serve food
and qualify for a leor license but when
I read the bill itself I I don't see
anything in the bill that would allow
for the qualification of a liquor
license all it really does is remove or
um the restriction on the surface of
food yeah you have to read the whole the
whole bill I mean the whole statute this
is just one line in the statute that
we're
amending representative uh Fargo if I
can answer the question Mr chairman
yes go ahead thank you um and for the
record represent represent thank you Mr
chairman I appreciate that
representative Faro it's pronounced
Banger not Bellinger um um thank you um
so yes as the chairman stated um cigar
bars are most of them I should say um I
don't want to generalize them already
are allowed to obtain a liquor license
so like like you pointed out yes all it
does is strike the um service of food
line they're already allowed to um
obtain a liquor license you know for
example one cigar bar in Portsmith uh
they sell cigars as well as are able to
uh sell
liquor for the question oh that answer
your question
okay great uh representative
hton thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Banger uh just want to
clarify this second Bill allows both
sale and service
of food am I
correct uh yes ma'am so M while the
first bill essentially says that they
may service food um my bill would allow
both say I decide I want to open up a
cigar bar I choose to um maybe not
charge my consumer for chips and salsa
mozzarella sticks whatever appetizer
type esque or even um to go beyond that
a burger um if I choose to provide that
service instead of charging my consumer
I can do that or I can charge my
consumer should I choose and again I'm
still required to sell 60% of my sales
of cigar products that
change brother question me that answers
your question thank you yes it does uh
is it your intent that restaurant style
food can be prepared and sold in cigar
bars you mentioned Burgers uh fries um
maybe steaks later
on
I mean I wouldn't foresee a stake being
sold at a cigar bar but again this
doesn't turn it into a restaurant it
allows for the service Andor sale of
food in a cigar bar what capacity of
that is subject to the um the
establishment and should the consumer
choose to pay for and or order that is
up to them but again requires that
establishment to have 60% of sales stay
as cigar um
sales thank
you it'll be a cheap stake uh
representative burz yes thank you yes it
probably would thanks for taking my
question um I guess I'm I'm confused I
understand the 60% rule about the cigars
but it seems to be creeping towards
being a restaurant so I'm wondering if
all the rules and regulations and
licenses that apply to restaurants such
as Safe Serve Etc would apply to the the
now the cigar bar with the
food you're you're free to answer
representative sorry
um thank you Mr chairman um yeah so I
mean no not really again you are
required to sell 60% of your sales via
cigars so this doesn't change you from
being a cigar establishment into a
restaurant it should be based on the
consumer
whether they should choose to go to this
restaurant and
and oh we just lost
him whoops I guess you have to log back
in uh so you're you'll have to wait with
your question Joyce and hopeing he'll
come back in
soon
um and
uh Max I put your hand down because you
are a co-sponsor you cannot ask a
question can I challenge the can I
challenge the rolling of the chair oh my
God no I'm serious about this this came
up uh last session in Municipal and
County and the resolution was that if
you didn't testify that you should all
should be allowed to ask questions no
the
the the other representative Belanger
Jim Belanger right before he retired
suggested that we remove that rule so he
and I work together with a house clerk
the house clerk emailed me back and said
there isn't a rule on co-sponsors asking
questions that that's just been a custom
and um it's it's left up to the the uh
the house if the house wants to add that
rule in we just haven't been doing it
but I have an actual open-end question
it's not a directed
question uh okay well uh well I'll come
back to you but let's right now uh Joyce
has a question for representative Banger
go ahead Joyce yes thank you um I don't
think that Anita's question was really
answered and that is whether or not all
of the rules about um restaurants would
apply in this situation I mean we have
to have real standards for preparing
food and the other question is I'm
wondering how this let's just stop with
that so you would like him to pursue
that question some more represent
lancher can you speak to that question
question uh thank you Mr chairman and
yes I do apologize I got bounced and it
must be a bad uh bad service um
so certain establishments are required
food establishments are required to set
to a certain standard right so obviously
if you are preparing food you are also
required to adhere to those standards
and again going back this does not turn
a cigar bar into a restaurant it just
allows them to service and or sell food
should the consumer choose to purchase
said
food
followup further question you may
inquire uh thank you um I'm wondering
about enforcement of this um how often
would how do you maintain that 60
40% uh balance and and who is going to
be making sure that that remains that
balance
remains is my question understood I'm
wondering how is this
enforced the same way it's already
enforced
now via liquor and law
enforcement so I I believe that's the I
believe that's the enforcement I I
apologize I don't fully know the answer
to that theoretically The Liquor
Commission uh can audit a u a cigar bar
and ensured that there sales just like
we actually had the food requirement for
restaurants that there Del liqu
commission audit does
audits so any other questions
representative won no thank
you okay representative aberson do you
have a question for representative
blanger yes it's an actual question okay
so we have about a dozen shops On the
Border in my district that uh sell
cigars and tobacco related products do
you know uh off the top of your head how
many different cigar shops there are
under this license throughout the state
and how much uh Revenue they're
generating so I mean I frequent a a
variety of them right so um there are
quite a few On the Border some in
Londoner Manchester seab Brook and
Portsmouth um to what end I don't
exactly what their revenues are um
but that'd be a good question uh excuse
me a good point to bring up um that I
could email the committee all right
thank you very
much okay um so any other questions from
Mr
blanger see done thank you very much um
so I don't have any other people signed
up to speak on this bill uh Aiden do you
do you mind just uh offering up what you
can tell us about the liquor
commission's enforcement of right now of
the cigar bars thank you Mr chairman can
you hear me okay now yes okay thank you
um I think this this bill uh presents
some interesting challenges for the
commission as far as how it would uh
apply it if the and I'm kind of walking
through this if the the legislature
carved out cigar bars with 17820 a as a
creature that
um has the ability to sell alcohol and
is
licensed but because of probably the
indoor smoking act and a few other
things have said has said you really
can't serve food and that's what section
2D
addresses if you were to allow the
business to sell food now
I believe we would probably interpret
that as now this becomes a
restaurant and would be required to
adhere to the health standards that are
exist uh at the state level and that the
facility would need to uh show that its
ability to they they wouldn't
necessarily demonstrate it to us but
they would probably demonstrated it to
the Department of Health or the local
health inspection office that their food
preparing facilities meet Health
standards so um it could very well
change the
category um and would would kind of
create a bit of a dilemma for us because
Cigar Bar license itself
um wouldn't of course as it was created
does not have food but if you're going
to now say you can prepare food uh we
would probably uh take an opinion that
this now we may force them or or require
them to get a restaurant license of some
type and I'm not sure we have an
adequate license type that would allow a
restaurant to have smoking indoors and
it may very well be in violation of the
indoor smoking act so there are there
are a number of issues I see um that
could
emerge uh based upon the passage of this
if it were going to be preparation and
service of food unlike uh the last bill
which allowed for you know the business
to merely put uh food on the bar or
wherever they place it like nuts or
pretzels or whatever um that's that's a
bit of a different creature but when you
talk about preparing the food um that
that changes the category
completely so um in terms of auditing uh
you know I I don't know how often you
guys audit cigar bars or um and kind of
light on staff would uh would we'd have
to revisit the um license fee because of
increased
auditing uh well the fee the chief
mentioned in in the last hearing that
the fee for this license was
$840 and the reason it it is $840 that
it is that is it is specifically not
considered
a restaurant if you look at the rest of
the licensing category in 17820 you'll
find that lenes that sell spirits and
that's what they're allowed to
do um have a cocktail lounge license
they pay
$1,200 but because of the fact that this
particular business can't sell
food then the decision was made that
they should be charged the same fee as a
what we refer to as a service bar
license so they uh that's where we get
the $840 as opposed to
$1,200 so if you were to um we we would
we look at the maintenance of these
figures um you know compliance because
it certainly if a business
uh chooses to say well you know I really
I got this license it was pretty easy to
get and I'm certainly not making any
accusations about any business but that
um they could fall out of compliance
fairly quickly if they are not attentive
to the tobacco side of their business
and spend most of their time on the
sales of alcohol so it is an area that
we frequently look at to ensure
compliance and I think the chief made a
reference to the fact that there's a uh
frequent uh challenges amongst the
existing lenses sometimes to keep them
in
compliance okay uh now we have more
questions if you're willing to take them
uh representative ham May
inquire thank you Mr chairman I just
wondered and it may not um necessarily
relate to serving food or not but what
are the air quality standards for cigar
bars you know as opposed to a restaurant
or other type
establishments what what are those
standards that might differ from a
restaurant um thank you for your
question representative I I uh I I I
won't waste time I don't know the answer
to that so uh I
apologize well I I can answer that since
I'm the one who wrote the original
indoor smoking act um on the Commerce
Committee I was the uh subcommittee
chairman of that bill that was related
to when we still allow restaurants to
have smoking but once we ban smoking in
restaurants that section for restaurants
was
mute but the indoor smoking act still
talks about being effectively segregated
in designated smoking areas and that
kind of stuff but again that's only for
non-
restaurants
businesses representative Herbert you
have a
question thank you chairman hunt
[Music]
um do we have any establishments left in
the state uh private places that serve
food maybe and smoking as well at the
same
time um I believe the only um facilities
that allow that are are social clubs
veterans
clubs um where um I think the public
policy has been made that uh veterans
should be uh allowed to have a place
where they can uh gather and have
alcohol in smoke if they wish so that's
my only the only place I'm aware of that
would possibly allow
that further question yes forther
question may inquire um thank you
um so
uh it's just it intrigues me uh
because u i mean in so another words a
Legion Post could uh put in
a cigar uh
facilities and uh do business there and
still serve food and it would be it's a
private club and uh that would be legal
under the law so as we sit here
today well a a military veterans Club
holds a license a club license under
17820 and um has been carved out of the
exception or exception has been created
for them in smoking it's not um I think
the public policy was this is a a group
that should be uh not necessarily swept
into the prohib prohibitions that exist
uh for restaurants um and I I would
where chairman hunt has authored the
indoor smoking act I would defer to him
for any greater detail on that
area right well the I think you're right
about there was also I think it was
Social Clubs so I guess what would be
the interesting question is to find out
is um how many uh uh social clubs are
out there that and you know not
withstanding whether they're V I think
they were all pretty much VFW you know
then um veterans but you know is there
is there another social club that has
been able to get a license um and I
guess because you could make the
arguments that smoking a cig is kind of
antisocial Behavior so if they're
they're doing that together that maybe
they should have a Social Club of their
own so it would be interesting to uh
find out if um if there's anything other
than
veterans but I would say that when it
came to the indoor smoking act the the
Social Clubs of veterans were
intentionally removed um from the bill
and then when later on when an attempt
to ban them from having smoking came up
um the
uh well let's put it nicely the
legislature and his wisdom felt that
that that those bills were they did not
want to pass them at that time you know
enforce that
regulation okay uh let's see uh
representative Emon has a
question yeah thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question I I
guess I'm speaking to Mr Moore yes you
are yes
your uh so my my first uh part is a
would you believe
um on F Street in Washington
DC there is a restaurant that allows you
to smoke cigars it's name is uh Shell's
back
room and you can eat dinner in
Washington
DC and you can order things like chicken
wings Burgers Pizza fries egg rolls
salads a very long menu of food uh I've
eaten there and I've smoked while I
while I ate so not far from the US
capital um I guess my question is is it
just because this business model doesn't
fit the current
bureaucracy and that's why that business
model is not legal and how does
Washington DC uh do it and New Hampshire
can't okay well I'll I'll take this
Aiden um when the prohibition ended the
21st amendment it didn't say okay
anybody you know there's no more
prohibition you know anybody's freefor
all it actually said uh more to the St
that each
state uh can then design and decide what
they wanted to legalize so theoretically
a state could have stayed dry um no
State chose to do that DC is obviously a
whole another animal because it's you
know it's in limbo there but so I can't
speak to the regulations and how you
know that obviously would be whatever
that DC Council they can do whatever
they want but it is true that the way
everything we've done in New Hampshire
here everything is is done our way um
not withstanding that we're one of the
19 controlled states where other states
Didn't Do It um and so
we and I agree it is very Byzantine the
way we do everything here and way what
we choose and what we choose didn't
choose you know why we have uh you know
we have we're protecting the three- tier
system but yet we um allow Brew PBS so
each one uh is a little chipping away at
whatever we thought was the the doctrine
that we were trying to manifest but at
the end of the day um this is what we
have and and and I can't say you say why
can you do it well it's because the
legislature has determined that that's
what they want to do so just a quick
followup yes for the question inquire um
so leaving out liquor uh cigars and food
right that's the other two components uh
is there a business model for cigars and
food without serving liquor the the
doctrine was I mean the doctrine was
that
uh cigar bars were kind of a new
phenomena that they were really just
just popped up in the more recent years
um and they for years were operating and
then they came in and said can we serve
liquor and the do and the policy at the
time and has and pretty much carried on
to this was well um no we don't want you
to you know we you know we we'll give
you liquor but you certainly don't want
to trample on the lights of restaurants
because all the restaurants are barred
from smoking or barred from having
cigars so you know how we're going to
you know it's not fair uh and certainly
you're putting towns in an awkward
position because um they were they each
town has the right to say no to whatever
regulations the liquor regulations we
come up with so we're kind of changing
the model because we said to them
originally that we would not
allow cigar bars to be restaurants at
that that was the original premise so uh
we are changing the rules of the game if
we were to pass this legislation and in
each City in town might have the right
to come back and say well gee we want to
rethink whether we allowed that Cigar
Bar in our town in the first
place that answer your
question uh yeah I think so okay great
Bonnie do you have another question is
your hands sorry sorry sorry now okay
anybody else have any more questions for
Aiden
Moore all right uh seeing none we we uh
I have nobody let me go to the attendees
I see a hand up Drew
Klein um I will promote uh Drew and Drew
uh after you testify would you please
make sure you go online and sign
up hello Mr Klein hi there I had to
unmute there so thank you U for having
me uh this is Drew Klein I'm president
of the jiia Bartlett Center for Public
Policy um not testifying in favor or
against just a neutral comment on this
legislation um so what I noticed in the
the discussion in the committee was that
all the discussion was focused on cigar
bars preparing their own F food and
serving food as if they were a
restaurant so preparing hot food having
a kitchen but I I think it's worth
pointing out that the way the rules work
now cigar bars are not allowed to serve
or sell food which means they are stuck
putting
um free snacks on the countertop so that
would mean essentially nuts and uh
cocktail nuts and pretzels basically
they actually can't right now on the
current law they're not allowed to
provide food what is
actually snacks I'm not allowed to
provide snacks I I'm sorry Mr chairman
um I I understand that in the law um if
you frequent cigar bars you will notice
that that still happens sometimes so
that's that's my shock shocked shocked
so um so my and my yeah so thank you for
the
clarification um so my point is um
what'll what'll sometimes happen is that
um free food will be offered that isn't
provided prepared uh at a cigar bar so
because the customers you if you're
sitting there smoking especially if
you're drinking you do want to have some
snack food so um so the previous bill
would allow you to serve um right snacks
so what I wanted to point out was the
difference between serving and selling
so under the previous bill you could
legally put the snack food out but
you're
still required to basically give it away
for free so under this bill um what you
would allow is not simply um I in other
words I don't think you should presume
that a cigar bar is in interested in
becoming a restaurant and preparing hot
food if cigar bars are allowed to sell
food that could also include and would
most likely primarily include packaged
prepackaged and food that is made
outside the facility so right now if a a
patron of a cigar bar wants to buy a
Snickers bar um or a muffin or a bagel
or a slice of pizza um that is prepared
off site that's not allowed so if you
allow the sale of food
I just wanted to point out that you
could allow um bars to sell uh slim gems
and beef jerky and other packaged items
that would be in demand when you're
sitting there drinking but that they
would be prohibited from selling um
under the first bill so um just just
something to point out that that the
language in the bill um might be able to
be worded in such a way um if the
members of committee were were extremely
opposed to allowing ing on premises
preparation of hot food to still allow
the actual retail sale of some types of
food so that that is all just wanted to
point out that distinction okay so um as
someone who's been around for all this
legislation um uh the leg uh we're we'll
pretend that we didn't hear you say that
they are providing snacks and we'll uh
go with what we thought we passed and
what we've always said is could be true
is that that if you're going to Cigar
Bar you could bring your own snack you
could bring I've heard stories of having
a pizza being delivered to a cigar bar
you know from a pizza delivery company
so um I I had I hear what you're saying
which is that maybe we should uh retain
this bill and somehow figure out some
way to uh look at what is currently
going on in some of these facilities and
making sure that we uh uh that that the
La is being abided and that we have
passed a law that is that is
enforcable well right I mean my comment
was just essentially to point out that
um you could work a law that would allow
the sale of prepared um uh prepackaged
or food that is prepared off premises um
that that would would be an option as
opposed to assuming that allowing the
sale means that they would have a
commercial kitchen and become a
restaurant fair enough uh so max you
have a question from
Mr Klein well I'm not sure if this
question might be better aimed at you um
if the intent of the law was that
somebody goes into a cigar bar you don't
want them to either either have food
delivered or order Uber Eats or maybe
you you don't even want legal I'm saying
that as far as I know it is perfectly
legal to have it delivered or you bring
it in with you it just said that that
the owner the facility is not permitted
to provide food under the current
statute so was it your intent that
people couldn't order food through the
owner or their employee and have it
delivered there or you wouldn't have the
owner employee physically handle the
food and put it in front of you or clean
up afterwards our intent was that the
owner would not had have anything to do
with um you know because our original
statant I don't even know if it's still
true I have to admit um was that the
this the actual cigar smoking room was a
bifurcated space uh and and um separate
and so that no employee would
technically have to be allow have to
walk into that smoking area um so you
know again how do you you know how do
you handle serving or picking orders or
food whatever if it's in a separate
little room so again I think that maybe
we can we can certainly retain this bill
and see to really down drill down to
what's actually going on in these spaces
and representative hunt if I'm still on
yes sir Drew Klein again and I just
should clarify I did didn't mean to
suggest that cigar bars were illegally
serving snacks so I I apologize if I
spoke um you know not precisely there
but people do bring snacks in and you
see people sharing their nuts and that
sort of thing so not trying to right
this time yes thank you that and that's
that's what you actually see and I
didn't mean to imply that people were
you know violating the law there great
thank you good is there any other
questions from Mr Klein all right seeing
we will close the public hearing uh on
House Bill
337 all
right and 30 okay so we can go right
into the next one uh House Bill 176
allowing beverage wi mix oh no we
just we just did that didn't we wa know
I'm confused which one
no that I think that was 171 that was
one yeah no well okay so
176 that was just 171 okay sorry all
right so now we're into 176 okay right
337 we were on we on we were on 337 and
now we're on to 176 okay that's what I
have there we go okay so run
76 and the prime sponsor want to raise
their
hands uh I have is
represented okay there she is all right
and I'm going to promote you oh I'm
trying to promote you what oh what
happened to
her RI MC Williams did you raise your
hand okay there you are okay now you you
can't go turning your hand on and off
you jump around on my screen okay all
right I am now promoting it to
panelists okay you're you're on
representative MC Willams welcome to the
Commerce Committee uh thank you so much
chairman hunt uh it's a pleasure to be
here again in front of my esteemed
colleagues I hope you're enjoying this
lovely snowy day here in February um I'm
here to testify about House Bill
176 um which is a bill to
um to allow beer and wine delivery for
uh food establishments that already have
a license to sell beer and wine on
premises um I do want to just check in
and make sure that everyone received the
amendment that I emailed um yesterday
afternoon uh you should check your email
if you haven't yet seen it uh basically
I updated the text of the bill to match
the same bill that's happening in the
Senate right now because uh there have
been a lot of discussions and
negotiations and I want to go through it
and make sure that we're all looking at
the same thing so um the amendment is
d02
61h um so we should all be looking at
that for for the correct text of the
bill um so originally when I had
proposed this bill it included mixed
drinks if you if you have the version
that talks about mixed drinks that's
wrong we're not talking about um liquor
we're just talking beer and wine um to
be super
um so as you probably know um the the
industry has certainly suffered quite a
bit during the Corona virus we're seeing
all kinds of innovative ways for
restaurant type establishments to figure
out how to make money um in the time of
Corona virus and so uh something that we
have allowed through emergency executive
order is for establishments uh to sell
beer and wine through delivery um also
you should know that from from the
history perspective on this bill this
was a bill that was being
negotiated during
2020 before the pandemic hit uh so this
um this has been a topic of discussion
to try to allow delivery of beer and
wine even before Corona virus but I
think Corona virus has certainly
exacerbated the need for a source of
revenue for establishments that
typically would have people coming to
have a meal and serve beer and wine and
since they're only doing takeout and
delivery they still need a way to sell
their inventory and also make that money
that they had expected in their business
plan um so uh just a quick spin through
this bill as proposed um once again no
references to um mix drinks if you see
that you're looking at the wrong bill um
really the purpose of this is to allow a
restaurant to um have their delivery
driver uh in many instances um a
W2 uh and they have to be 21 years of
age uh to deliver both food and the
paired wine and beer that go with the
food um as part of the delivery there
were some concerns about um people
ordering to public establishments and to
college campuses so you'll see on page
two there's all kinds of language
prohibiting that those acts you can't
deliver to a college campus you can't
deliver to a public library public
playground or public park you actually
have to be going to a private address um
that's not to say that someone who's
creative couldn't come up with some
other establishment that's not listed
here but the idea is to make sure that
um this really is for private
consumption of beer and wine not in the
public um so uh the intent is that it
would be effective July 1
2022 um I suppose we could play with the
effective date seeing as there is a
sister Bill happening in the Senate as
well and and certainly the industry
needs it sooner rather than later um but
nonetheless that really is the concept
here is to enable what's already going
on through um emergency order to become
on the books because we have learned
that some of the emergency orders are
really great and perhaps we should make
them uh legislation so I'm not by any
means an expert on this and there will
be people after me who can testy testify
a little bit more on the Nuance to this
bill um but I'm happy to take any
general questions if you have
them Mr chair you're
muted yeah I was printing all this stuff
so yes so representative Johnson please
go forward with your
question thank you for letting me have
my question one do we know what the
Senate
bill is in relation to this
one uh the Senate bill is 66 the
language matches exactly this
amendment thank you sure thing uh
representative mcle um thank you Mr
chairman uh currently if I'm in a
restaurant and I order a bottle of wine
and it's uh I drink half of it I can
take the other half home if it's
properly sealed I can also go to a uh
a brew pub and get a a Grog of uh of
beer and that they seal and Etc so in in
this particular Bill I just quickly I
just printed it out quickly reading
through it um is it possible that that
this bill would say that you have to
order a
unsealed bottle of wine or
a excuse me a sealed bottle of wine or
sealed beer in other words you couldn't
get necessarily A Grog delivered but you
could get a six pack or you couldn't get
a a kff of wine that was poured at the
bar but you could buy a bottle of wine
is there any distinction
there oh that's an excellent question um
I too am looking at the language of the
bill for an answer to that question and
I don't see something about seiling or
partially open in the bill um so that
does bring up an interesting question if
you're asking for a partial I can I I
can answer this question okay so and
obviously Aiden will speak but uh it'll
help um I'm going to premise this so it
helps everybody visualize what's
happening here and that is uh the Liquor
Commission does not want anything that's
partially made or open or Avail
potentially could be taint you know
tainted with somebody you know doing
something to it so if they're going to
deliver wine they're going to deliver it
in a sealed
bottle and I also let you know represent
mcams believe it or not there could be
liquor uh uh involved in this
transaction uh because uh the way the
bill is written it says Beverages and uh
we have expanded beverages to include
distilled um alcohol um but they are
they're limited to eight% so you can oh
what's he saying why is he doing this
I'm sorry Aiden did I did
I you're muted Aiden so I just want to
make sure everybody knows that that what
is distributed what is what is sold has
to be in a sealed container uh and again
by the manufacturer and not from the
facility but U I'll give you a chance
Aiden to correct me once you're once you
get on okay so go ahead uh you have
another question I guess we what else it
representative
Herbert thank you chairman hunt
uh uh I think I think I'm talking to
Aiden I suppose I don't know but you
want wait to wait to ask him when he
gets on you can but right now you're
questioning representative M mams well I
can I'm not the expert you don't want to
ask me expert
questions okay I'll wait okay okay great
uh representative
gon H good morning representative
Williams and thank you for taking our
questions this morning uh my question
has to do with holding the restaurant
the bartender the waiter the delivery
driver harmless uh if the uh if the the
person the customer that's receiving the
product should then go about and get in
their vehicle and and drive and get a DI
get a DUI or kill somebody or something
like that whereas when alcohol is
consumed on premise there's the control
and I know you have the language in the
bill with the maximum amount of that can
be sold but there's uh there's can
there's no language in the bill dealing
with holding the EST establishment
harmless and would this be something you
might consider or do you need to
consider
this I think that that question is best
for for Aiden Moore okay well then I
will defer to Aiden Moore great thank
you representative
Aon all right thank you and thank you
for taking my question um I'm reading in
the uh amended bill that uh that you
sent us that you'd have no deliveries at
all to any college or university um were
you aware that the median age at some of
our community colleges is is 26 and that
we have some uh we have some
colleges um and some programs that are
aimed at uh continuing education where
you probably couldn't find anyone on the
campus under
21 um I I am aware of that um and thank
you so much for your question I just
want to highlight that this is a
negotiated compromise with the language
um so clearly you can see that there's
some concern about overindulging or uh
perhaps immature drinking behavior and
that was sort of the intention to make
sure that this bill does not enable
that all right thank you very much okay
uh repres Senor
Herbert thank you chairman
hunt um Mr Moore Aiden Moore uh
no no not yet we're still representing
MC Williams
here sorry you just still add your hand
up I'm sorry I'm
confused all right is there any other
questions for representative
McWilliams great thank you very much
seeing none thank you so much I I have
to go testify on another bill but thank
you again for the opportunity to present
and I'll Circle back yeah no problem
okay you're on now
Aiden thank you Mr chairman can you hear
me okay yes I can uh first I I apologize
for or uh I had unmuted myself and I
have a couple of phones going at the
same time so uh my comments sure you
weren't talking about me when you said
not not not not one second sir not not
for one second okay um and I need to
mute your phone yes yes I have to get
rid of these phones I think sometimes
um thank you uh for allowing me to
approach this as as uh representative MC
Williams indicated um
the uh Amendment which we just saw is
essentially what the Senate has been
working on in Senate Bill
um what Senate Bill 66 represents is
essentially what was being worked on
last session and subject to the
executive order of the governor for the
sale and service of uh alcohol with food
um for consumers and uh what we see in
in the amendment which uh again is uh
the same as 66 are adequate safeguards
which we believe um if followed will
ensure that uh these licenses have the
ability um to continue this process
we've had about a Year's worth of this
effort um my conversations with Chief
armaganian who's also available is that
have been uh no discernable violations
of of the executive order uh that would
have uh caused us to
reconsider this policy and that it seems
to have been worked out fairly well um
we cannot provide you with details I
made a an inquiry to uh the New
Hampshire restaurant and Lodging
Association trying to get a sense of how
many businesses took advantage of this I
I was not able to uh get a an accurate
number so I can't tell you with any
degree of certainty how many businesses
may take advantage of this opportunity
in the uh post pandemic world uh but um
we we seem to be very satisfied that
this amendment which is consistent with
Senate Bill
66 um is uh reasonable and and
enforcable and continues the policy that
the Governor established through his
executive order and I'd be happy to take
any questions if any of the committee
members would
like okay representative Herbert you
have a
question thanks again the
chairman um I'm just curious uh my
question is I know a lot of states have
takeouts uh and you have uh for example
they'll they'll you could take out a
mix right and uh bring your own tequila
I suppose I'm not sure how that works
but
uh I'm just wondering why what was the
uh objection to mixed
drinks uh was it because they were not
would be sub maybe not so uh healthy or
they wouldn't be
closed uh properly and that was that it
was a health issue or what was the
problem with mixed drinks I mean if
you're gonna if you're GNA sell uh wine
and beer uh um I don't understand myself
why you wouldn't do uh mixed drinks as
well but uh I saw my question to you is
what was the uh what was the concern
there well thank you for your question
representative I I believe
uh the I I I believe as representative
hunt mentioned the P last session um uh
created a new opportunity for re
retailers both on premise and off-
premise as they uh saw the ability to
sell uh an expanded uh portfolio of
beverages that fit under what a
classification called a uh specialty
beverage um and so we never really got
to the question of um sales of spirits
and mixed drinks the uh the consumer
does have the ability to order and have
delivered uh any of the products that
may be considered a you know what what
what we refer to is in slang as a Cann
cocktail so long as it is within the uh
eligible portfolio that the on premise
license e can
sell um so we've really not got to the
question for Spirits I think one of the
things that has presented itself in
other states is the question of sealing
and and preserving the Integrity of
these products um because they are mixed
at the site and uh so we we never we
never got to the final bottom line of
you know is this something um that we
should support or not support but we did
have experiences with uh other states
who have had challenges in their
application of uh these Provisions that
included mixed drinks so I'm not sure if
I've responsive to your question sir but
uh we we never got to the bottom line
about whether we should add mixed drinks
or not I just have one other question uh
if it's all right chairman hunt other
question you may inquire
um an executive order of the
governor allowed for this this service
to be
provided um but
the does that mean the governor has the
uh authority to if he changed his mind
to add mixed drinks to it without going
through the
legislation I mean I think your sense
that I didn't know the governor had that
kind of executive order
Authority well to me but what what I
think is important for you to toh be
aware of Representative is last year
there was a bill that was making its way
through the Senate uh when the pandemic
hit and um the governor's office was in
search of methods to assist this
industry and one of the things that we
had um in the process of being at least
vetted by the legislature was that
Senate Bill allowing for uh the uh ship
or the sale uh of alcohol with food to
Consumers and uh so therefore when the
governor was looking for a an approach
we offered this uh legislation as
something that uh he might consider as
part of his executive order so um that
was reviewed by his staff and I'm sure
whatever legal team that he had in place
and um the decision was made to to move
forward with that uh I can't speak to
the uh powers of the governor Beyond
that and I think uh you would probably
get an opinion from maybe your house
counsel about what the powers of the
governor are in in an executive order uh
framework but uh I'm not sure whether or
not he could add it or not but it was
not part of the bill that was being
entertained last year just one more
chairman hun if I might okay so are are
the are the restaurants able to do this
now or are they waiting for this
legislation to get
true um well they've had the ability to
do this under the executive order I
cannot tell you with any certainty
whether or not that those orders have
expired or not um you may I'm not sure
if Mr Mike Summers from the restaurant
and Lodging Association is signed up to
testify on this or not um but so I I
would I would probably let Mr Summers uh
feel that question sir if it's okay with
me uh representative
gson uh yes thank you uh Mr Moore for
taking our questions my my question was
originally uh presented to
representative MC Williams uh but I was
told that you would probably be better
able to answer it and so the question is
presently uh when alcohol is consumed on
premises uh the waiter the bartender the
manager can control the amount of
alcohol and be able to refuse service to
somebody they they would believe would
be uh inebriated and if they were to
continue to serve some somebody they
could be held responsible after even
after that person leaves well here now
we have the delivery of alcohol uh off
premises uh at what point is the
restaurant the bartender whatever the
delivery driver no longer uh responsible
for that other person when can they
still be held or are they held harmless
once they once they've made the the
delivery and should this bill
specifically address the issue of being
held
responsible thank you uh thank you for
your question representative I think the
the uh the issue um that you've
described is um one where we have to
kind of look at the at the technical
aspects of the law and that uh the
delivery driver who would be a W2
employee of the business uh has every
right and obligation that this product
this alcoholic beverage should not be
sold or delivered to a person who's
under 21 or to an intoxicated person um
on the question of liability I would
probably refer you to RSA 507 F which is
the alcoholic beverage leny liability
act and um what you're describing is
certainly probably a novel question uh
if if a uh if some type of claim were
made against a license e under 507 F uh
but I think as long as the delivery
person uh makes sure that the alcohol is
not delivered to a minor or to a person
who's
intoxicated um it is not something that
would most likely uh reflect back on the
lensey for some type of administrative
action I'm not sure if that is
responsive to you or not sir I hope
so you all set Jeff uh it it just brings
up concerns about putting all that on
the delivery
driver um and I would say that is why um
the commission is very strongly in
supported the idea that the only the
only people who can take uh deliver is
the actual restaurant license you know
under the restaurant itself and that and
and if I if I remember correctly and I
and I apologize for over over my bounds
here but did did the does the uh the the
proposed Bill say that the delivery
driver actually has to be 21 or over as
well I know the recipient has to be but
does a delivery driver have to
be that's that one's for you Aiden I
don't I didn't see that though um yes
they have to be at least 21 years of age
okay that would be on uh Representatives
representative MC Williams Amendment on
page two uh lines 1 through
three
okay right uh paragraph yeah section
five I'm afraid I don't have the the
amended version so I'm I'm shooting in
the dark here on that one okay SE okay
thank you uh representative
Fargo yes thank you Mr chairman um I had
a question as I read the amendment um
and it talks about
the consumers who are who
appear visibly intoxicated or who AR
reasonable and prudent person would know
are intoxicated who do not produce
identification or who failed to sign a
receipt would not be entitled to his or
her delivery well what if they are
intoxicated and they do produce
identification and they do sign a
receipt then
what
does the delivery person continue to I
mean I I just think the wording in the
amendment leaves an Open Door there that
um you could still deliver to someone
who's intoxicated am I reading that
incorrectly uh thank you for your
question representative Fargo I I think
the um intent is that the driver I mean
if you were to look at the um the
delivery driver
in the same vein that you would look at
a
bartender um the bartender would go
through the appropriate assessments
looking at the customers you know
looking at their age how old are you
their state of intoxication and RSA
1795 has a legal obligation that
the Jesus excuse
me that the uh that the uh bartender has
a legal obligation not to to make the
sale uh to persons who are uh either
underage or or intoxicated those types
of criteria are now extended to the
delivery driver who will have to make
the same assessment I can assure you
that with the passage of this law uh the
commission has a very
vigorous and aggressive alcohol
education program and that this would be
part of any uh
program content moving forward that the
commission would try to make sure that
these businesses understood what the law
says and how they should apply it so
that it's consistent with the
legislative
intent uh of uh of chapter chapter 178
and
179 so I'm not sure if I answer your
question representative I hope I have
um um further question inquire yes I I I
understand your answer I'm just
wondering if perhaps the amend needs to
be tightened up to specifically say what
you what you should just shared with us
because I think right now the way that
it reads is is
questionable thank
you okay any other questions for
attorney
more okay um um uh representative uh
getting in L Lon I'm I I apologize I
didn't see you over there in the
attendees so um if you would like to
bring in oh John you you got your hand
up uh thank you Mr chair I have my hand
up my phone rang I put my hand down okay
my question is to uh Mr Mo would in as
much as I am a licensed server I went
through the course I got my my
certificate that I'm a licensed server
would it would it do well if the bill
included the fact that the delivery
driver would also have to be a licensed
server because we went through all the
courses with how to identify all these
traits of someone who should not be
served uh and that's my question thank
you thank you for your question
representative
um the commission does not license um
servers um we provide
education um and that education for the
servers voluntary there is no uh
requirement that they participate in
education I think there are some
incentives that would be well served for
the
ly um in making sure that if they uh
choose to go down this path of taking
advantage of this type of delivery that
they make sure that their employees are
educated uh about the law and to take
advantage of the free uh ly education
programs was offered by the commission
they may also potentially inquire from
their insurance carrier whether or not
the participation in uh education
programs may very well bring them some
type of Premium reduction if they show
that they have educated their staff uh
in a preventative sort of fashion so
I've hope I've answered your question
representative thank you a perfect so uh
now representative Lon
would you like to
[Music]
testify maybe not okay uh no
Lon you uh me representative Lon I'm
sorry yes yes um yes all I wanted to
basically say I'm sorry well for one
thank you Mr chairman and whoever
responded to my email quickly uh I found
out about this late but I just basically
wanted to say um you know I am
representative Stacy Marie lton I
represent Hillsboro County District 31
downtown nashar and I um I just want to
just just briefly say I support uh this
uh house bill um to allow establishments
to uh deliver these kinds of products um
just because from the perspective of a
consumer um you know last last summer
when you're shut down and you're trying
to stay safe but it's still like to you
know you don't want to go to the grocery
store but you want to consume an adult
beverage um it it it would have been
nice to have been able to do so uh it
would have made quarantine I think feel
a little more uh normal sometimes so uh
just that's all I really wanted to say
was just uh I encourage uh the committee
to to uh you know you know approve it
and bring it to the full house so we can
uh pass it on a full house
level
fair
enough uh any questions for represent L
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony okay
now Mike Summers
who there you good morning Mr chairman
good
morning uh thank you for the opportunity
to uh talk to you this morning about uh
HB 176 for the record my name is Mike
Summers I'm the president CEO of the New
Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association um we are in support of this
bill as uh under the proposed amendment
um to give a little history in this
space um we had started an effort back
in late 2019 working with the Liquor
Commission uh and Senate of French on
bringing forward a bill that would allow
for beer and wine delivery um and then
of course um the world ended and we had
the pandemic and the governor was kind
enough to uh essentially adopt that U or
give us that right under an emergency
order which has been very helpful for
some businesses
um so obviously uh we are very
supportive of this effort to essentially
codify on a permanent basis what
essentially the effort we had started uh
a year ago um to make this permanent and
you know I I would encourage that uh you
know time is a bit of the essence we
don't know when the emergency order will
end and obviously the industry would
like to retain this right as we continue
to fight to survive this pandemic and
then recover on the other side of it so
we're certainly uh supportive of both uh
this this amended version of the bill in
the house and and the Senate version
Senate Bill
66 we do have a little bit of a concern
with the effective date uh notice it was
July 1st of uh of
2022 uh and as I just stated uh not
knowing when the emergency order ends it
would be nice if we could move that date
up to say uh July 1st of 2021 um and
hopefully that there is no lapse in this
uh the ability for restaurants to
participate in this activity so that
would certainly be very
helpful um and then beyond that I have
have responses to a number of questions
that were asked um I'm not sure if I
want to drill into this too much but you
know one of the questions that was asked
was about um the current right that most
uh uh folks visiting a restaurant have
which is to uh open and enjoy part of a
bottle and then take the remains of that
bottle home with you that is a different
part of the statute and frankly I think
that that right would still be retained
I don't think this would affect it
they're two totally separate issues um
so that would still be in place and then
we would still be be able to do uh the
the delivery of beer and wine in their
unopen containers and I would also say
that the one thing that um we we haven't
really touched on but I think it's very
important for you to understand for the
industry is is that these beers and
wines are also available for takeouts so
if I'm picking up a pizza at a local
pizza shop I can grab a six-pack of beer
or a bottle of wine or whatever they may
have available again the limitations all
in place and uh so that has also been a
a very important component of this uh
for for these businesses as we've worked
through this pandemic
so
um I think I would leave it with that
and I would I i' would try to answer any
questions that the the committee may
have uh we do have a question
representative abenson has a
question Yeah you mentioned the uh the
effective date of the bill um would
would you be amendable to something like
60 days within passage um it's
possibility that the bill could be
retained until next year so
um outside possibility but do you think
it it would be preferable to just do 60
days within the passage of the bill
whenever the bill ends up getting passed
sure whatever the you know the will of
the committee is uh I would just
encourage you that sooner is better
because not knowing when all of this may
lift I think the one concern we have is
that you know we would have a lapse in
the ability to to participate in this
and so um you know 30 days 60 days
whatever you may deem uh appropriate um
but I but I believe and I don't want to
speak on behalf of the Senate but I
believe the Senate is committed to
fast-tracking Senate Bill 66 so that is
the uh the Senate version of of this
amendment so uh so I would I would
certainly encourage and ask this
committee to move quickly because I
think we would very much like to see
this done in an expeditious manner all
right thank you for the
question uh representative van
hton thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony Mr Summers did you
just say that partial bottles say of
wine be deliverable under this bill in
your estimation no no um there is a
current piece in the statute that allows
that if you go and you dine in a
restaurant not for take out of delivery
but if you dine in a restaurant and you
uh you and you're with a you know a
guest you may have a glass of wine each
you may have a half a bottle left over
at the end of the meal uh under certain
conditions it has to be corked it has to
be in a bag that's stapled shut um and
you know once you transport in the
vehicle it has to be Out Of Reach of the
driver that kind of thing in under
certain circumstances that you can take
home the remainder of that bottle of
wine it does not apply for the takeout
and delivery thank
you um Mike you want to talk about
section two of the bill the
transportation of beverage and wines and
what's what's in there that's different
than what we've been talking about so
far so section two says transportation
of beverage and
wines this a person may transport
deliver beverage and wines the state
without a license provided such beverage
and wines were obtained as authorized by
this title and provided such beverage
and wines are consumption only and not
for resale
purposes so I I guess what is your
question question Mr chair what would
you like me to address we're sitting
here talking about
lenses um such as yourselves delivering
it and then I we got this amendment from
represent MC Lam and then I had from
your from Henry saying this is word for
word for what you guys wanted so I
thought maybe you can explain to me what
the section two is all about well so so
In fairness section two and and Aiden
may want to step in and correct me but
we simply took that language directly
from another part of the of the LIC of
the statute where it talks about right
now as a as a restaurant employee um I
may go down to the liquor store purchase
product on the license for the
restaurant and transport it back to the
facility or I may go to sell Warehouse
in Bow and pick up our weekly delivery
and transport it and so the language
that is in that section I believe is
word for word what is in uh that other
section where it allows for employees to
transport uh uh beverages on behalf of
the of the
establishment okay so I'll ask Aiden
this question but representative V hton
do you have a question from Mr sumers
your all set okay uh so Aiden can you
tell me what section two is all about
here what this is
is this allowing employees to pick up
wine and bring it back to the to the
restaurant is that what this is about
because it says it's repealed and
reenacted so I assume something's going
on here are you there
Aiden it's probably on the phone how
about you mark are you
there uh so so so as far as you know
even though it says repeal and reenacted
you don't know there's anything new in
there or
anything and actually as i r reread it
Mr chairman I believe that is exactly
the language and you know one of the
requirements is that the the um the
employee of the licensee has to carry a
copy of the license in the vehicle at
all times where they're transporting
beverages so that's going to be
reflective um uh on the delivery drivers
as well so they would have to have that
a copy of the of the facility's license
on them again for for uh you know just
verification purposes but but I am
positive that that is a specific
language that is in the transportation
of uh beverages to the facility we're
now talking about Transportation away
from the facility but essentially it's
the same
language yeah it's just so weird it says
repeal and reenact so I'm just trying to
figure out what was changed and and and
that frankly is a piece that uh would
have been put in I Believe by
um OS I don't I don't believe that was
any that uh we would necessarily have
asked for right or or the Senate because
this amendment is coming from the Senate
right correct yeah okay I'll give them
one more time so Aiden or Mark or either
one of you still still
online yes not okay and Chris your hands
up just because you haven't do you have
a new question
Chris yes yes I do okay um um when I
first uh thought about this I said oh
I'll take out in other words you always
see the people coming in then taking out
and they're going to be the consumers
it's their meal they're going back home
this bill now has like the delivery the
Uber guy and and whatnot and so there's
this intermediate uh you've opened up
this intermediate uh delivery so at that
time neither the consumer nor the
premise uh has any control over what's
going on and that kind of surprised me
so I'm are there other states that do
this we're gonna be talking about that a
little bit on the next bill but I do I
believe Mike Will does have very strong
opinion about he would like us to let us
know about this bill and as related to
that subject well so uh just to clarify
in this language of this bill uh the
amendment and again I think you just
received it so I I appreciate that fact
um I believe that the only person person
who can deliver on behalf of the ly must
be an employee of the ly so an Uber or
somebody else cannot be involved in
delivery of alcohol they may deliver
meals still just like they they may
already but they cannot deliver alcohol
and frankly that was a control that was
um uh encouraged and pushed for by the
LI liquor enforcement and we we agre
conceded to that because we understood
the chain of custody was going to be uh
a big part of the discussion should
there be a liability question and so uh
my understanding is that that would not
be allowed under this the way this is
drafted right now a third-party delivery
uh uh company would not be able to
deliver alcohol on behalf of a
l right and that's that's really the
whole point is that right and and I
think Aiden might be back on so he may
be able answer that question as well
right so Aiden are you can you talk I
can you hear me sir yes we can oh thank
you
um um I guess the the question is the
whether or not a third party is eligible
to deliver under this amendment is that
do I understand that
correctly yes and and I would agree with
Mr Summers that the answer is no um the
reason that we are looking for having it
as a W2
employee um is
to provide a direct opportunity for us
to take sanctions against the business
if in fact a violation were to take
place that's certainly not our intent to
go out to try to violate a business but
if uh if they are unable to follow the
provisions in the law then we want to
have recourse against the l e if that is
done incorrectly um without getting too
much in the weeds a third-party delivery
system creates something that is
referred to in the law as an intervening
event and the intervening uh event kind
of cuts off the
process um and we have a question of of
title who takes delivery of the product
and when do they take delivery of the
product and a lot of that is U those are
issues which we uh find to be uh
challenging to get answers to and and
therefore the easiest approach to this
and probably the one that I think Mr
summes and his members felt comfortable
with is that uh confining it to W2
employees would provide uh the best
recourse for for his industry as well as
the Commission in case there were
problems would you agree to that Mr
Summers that that's
fair this is not a
conversation oh sorry sir I apologize
but he could he can move his head up and
down that's perfect so all right so um
so now that I have you a and I forward
the EMA this amendment to you did you
get it yes sir I did thank you okay so
can you explain what section two is
trying to do do for
us
uh you might not have read that far um I
um if you could give me a minute to
digest it and um I'll I don't know if
there are other questions that members
might have that well the interesting the
reason we got here is because I started
looking at the effective date of the
bill and then I saw section one and
section two had two different effective
dates and then then I go what is this
all about and um it it it um so if you
want to think about that anymore all
right so are you speaking about lines 6
through 11 so I you know again I know
what what I'm looking at is if you were
to this is really page
three of the amendment to House Bill
176 it's page three okay and it starts
on page two but it says repeal and
reenact transportation of Beverages and
wine
uh I I I would say I I I I it would be a
mistake for me to just offer something
so uh Pam I I know I don't know you're
you're tracking us and you probably
heard me ask this question have did you
have you got any insight on what's
happening there in that
section I'm sorry I'm I'm here but I am
working on other things so I wasn't okay
that's fine no problem
all right well um I don't know I guess
we'll we'll have to get more detail on
figure out what's happening there so
we'll stay tuned on that one it's just
frustrating that we don't have
subcommittees so we can't really deal
with it but at this point um I guess we
we'll see a senate version come over so
by that time we'll know whatever
whatever's in the Senate bill so okay uh
so does anybody have any questions for
Aiden we all set okay
and uh the attendees anybody attending
anybody would like to speak speak now
forever more hold your
piece uh oh oh okay here we do oh Kate
I'm sorry I did have you on my list okay
sorry all right so Kate fry sorry I I
gonna promote you to
speak so I
apologize
there she is delay see see this see this
is the delay that's why I'm trying to
promote people prematurely yeah go ahead
Kate Hi hi representative I knew you
wouldn't forget about me um good good
afternoon members of the committee um my
name is Kate fryan the vice president of
advocacy at new futures um we are
opposed to houseb 176 I did send you all
testimony earlier today I will say it
was based on the original bill that
included cocktails to go I was not aware
of the amendment and I have not seen the
amendment um but regardless we still
have concerns about this bill and the
delivery of even beer and wine I mean as
we've heard already there is an
executive order in place which currently
allows for this I still haven't really
gotten an understanding of how many
restaurants have actually you know taken
advantage of this what has been the Vue
increase around this whether or not
it'll be necessary after the pandemic um
and it's certainly concerning to me that
even the Liquor Commission doesn't
really have a great take on that too and
I think before we go ahead and move
something into a permanent law that
really shifts our policy structure we
need a much better understanding of that
um I will just go on to say too and
you've hear me say this over and over
again I'm a broken record but we do have
to understand understand the costs of um
alcohol misuse not only in the country
but in the state and every time we talk
about um bills like this which increases
um accessibility we have to understand
that there's going to be further impact
um you know the numbers were already
very very high when we talk about um the
you know the major driver of mortality
with alcohol 88,000 deaths a year and
that was prec covid we're actually
hearing um from some data that I have in
my testimony that um alcohol consumption
has increased quite a bit among
subgroups within the population with um
covid and the patterns of alcohol um
sales have shifted from on premise to
off- premise
sales and there's certainly a lot of
public health risk with off- premise
sales um and there's a lot of stronger
association with um harms increased
rates of violence alcohol Hospital
admissions impair driving because you
have to remember when somebody is doing
more drinking off premises the public
safety guards in place like servers are
not there um so uh you know we have real
concerns about um uh delivery of alcohol
I I think the amendment and um the
Senate version might address this a
little bit as far as um the delivery and
and um a little bit more regulation from
The Liquor Commission
um but I really think that we need to
look very closely that all the best
practices are in place um in the second
page of my testimony you will see a link
to best practice guidance for alcohol
sales and deliveries during and after
the co um pandemic and I would encourage
the committee and um the you know Liquor
Commission and others involved in
writing this to make sure that really
those best practices are in place you
know and I will underscore the fact that
while beer and wine um you know we can
live with that as long it's within the
structure of um at least the amendment
we would have major concerns with
cocktails to go um just because of the
issues around sealed and
unsealed um it it goes on and on a lot
of states have experimented with this
and um it's just a very difficult thing
to regulate are we talking about a cup
with a straw in it or are we talking
about something that's sealed um I just
think we need a lot more information
before we move in that direction uh let
me just make sure I don't have anything
else for my
testimony that concludes my testimony
I'm happy to take questions if there are
any
great thank
you I don't see any questions so I think
you're all set thank you very much okay
next up is Jamie Jamie
Bernett thank you Mr chairman can you
can you hear me yes we can all right
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh my name is Jamie Bernett
I'm here today representing the wine
Institute uh the wine Institute
represents over a thousand California
wineries and Affiliated businesses and
we support HB
176 uh we believe that the legislation
is timely uh and essential for New
Hampshire restaurants uh who as we all
know are struggling with the economic
Fallout from covid-19 uh and this would
provide a much needed benefit for them
and and their customer
um wineries too have been hard hit by
the loss of sales to on premises lienes
revenue losses uh due to
covid-19 uh for thousands of wineries
could reach into the billions of dollars
uh just in 2020 alone uh and while um
while direct a consumer shipment uh has
increased during the pandemic um it it
doesn't compensate for the loss and
revenue uh to to sales to on premises
lenses so uh while we support HB 176
there were some changes we were going to
recommend but in light of Representative
Mick Williams uh testimony and the other
testimony we've heard today um I think
those will be addressed in the amendment
we have not seen the amendment yet but
we have seen the Senate Bill uh and that
is something that we are also supportive
of uh one of those changes briefly uh
was on the total amount of wine that
could be uh delivered in a u in one sale
uh I think the original Bill had it 192
ounces we support the 1.5 leaders uh as
as a maximum uh which is in the Senate
Bill uh I would also note just for
background that there are several other
states that um have either uh passed
similar legislation or are considering
um similar legislation right now
including um Rhode Island Main and
Connecticut Are all uh considering
similar legislation
um States like Massachusetts California
New York um have passed this on a
temporary basis and States like Ohio
Iowa and Oklahoma and Washington DC have
passed it on a permanent basis so um
with that uh we'll look forward to um
supporting the bill uh as amended um and
happy to answer any questions you might
have okay any
questions um so I see none and uh just
for uh the members uh steuart Tracy used
to do the wine Institute he's since
retired and Jamie is taking over for for
the wine
Institute thank Mr yep and welcome
aboard I see no questions so we're all
set thank you very much and last but not
least is uh Brian
Moren good morning Brian good morning
thank you chairman hunt and members of
the committee we appreciate the
opportunity to speak to you today uh my
name is uh Brian ran I'm director of the
government Affairs for the New England
convenience store and energy marketers
Association we represent convenience
stores and gasoline retailers uh in New
Hampshire and according to the National
Association convenience stores there are
almost 900 stores in New Hampshire 655
which sell motor fuels we employ over
14,000 people uh just wanted to say NEX
understands and appreciates the
well-intentioned motivations in the
legislation to address the economic
impacts uh the pandemic has leveled on
all retailers uh and especially the H
restaurant and hospitality industry
however nexum is opposed to hp76
176 um you know as the pandemic unfolded
in March and the executive orders were
made we did not oppose Governor suu's
executive orders that provided this
flexibility for Relief uh for on
premises
Peres however to make these Provisions
permanent is unwarranted given that
Statewide vaccinations are expected to
be largely completed by this fall
whereupon one can reasonably expect
remarkable and widespread return to
in-person
socialization and accompanying Pat
patronization of restaurants and on
other off premise or on premise uh
permites if this doesn't happen then the
executive orders will likely still
remain in place and these relief
measures will continue un and
uninterrupted uh and the reason is prior
to the pandemic there was no necessity
for these measures so why should there
be one after the state of emergency
orders are lifted
it by passing this bill the committee
may be unintentionally picking winners
in this category as the shape of the
post pandemic retail will continue to
evolve this is not Equitable to those
already in this category nor appropriate
especially since there is no lack of
outlets for purchasing Beverages and
wine across the state nexima suggests
the committee instead consider an
emergent post vaccine
viewpoint on this issue as opposed to
this immediate Horizon we still in in
doing in doing so a course of action
would involve continued Reliance on the
executive orders and once rescinded
revisit the necessity and justification
for any continuation of the measures
currently
authorized at that point in time the
true need and necessity will be much
clearer nexim encourages the members to
vote against this bill and re-evaluate
its need and particularly the
justification for it once widespread
vaccinations are achieved and the de
emergency declarations are
lifted thank you very much uh if you
have any questions be happy to answer
any uh we do representative buroughs has
a
question yes thank you for taking my
question um and that is um do you
believe that uh that during the pandemic
it's there's certain Market disruptions
that have happened and have brought in
new ways of doing business and um in
some cases these are actually Market
Innovations so do you think that mean I
think some of these Innovations may
actually be positive so I guess my
question is if this you know because it
may benefit another segment of the
market is is that a reason to to vote
down the bill
no I think it's um I think there's a
real key point to understand how big of
a problem are we really solving with
passage of this bill and that you know
we're all for an open competitive
Marketplace and I believe you know and
even uh Mr Summers couldn't identify in
his
testimony how many restauranter have
taken advantage of this and tracked it
and said you know this is something
that's really important and to me that I
think is something that really needs to
be looked at before the state takes
action on this bill and particularly as
it relates
to how retail is going to evolve post
pandemic hopefully that does that get at
your question yes thank you thank
you representative Abel has a question
Mr Moran thank you for your uh for your
testimony I wonder if you have any uh
evidence uh of uh of damage or or
uh losing uh your your the stores losing
in your segment losing uh losing um
sales uh because of the because of the
executive order um if you do or can sort
of generalize about that that would be
very
helpful sure thank you for your question
um I can't specifically identify uh
drops and sales as it relates to uh our
beer and wine
sales however we can point to S probably
a 20 to 30% drop
um and sales overall in our
stores okay uh
so uh Brian um isn't it true that right
now
your uh off- premise licenses are
permitted to
deliver beer and wine to Consumers
correct
so if I understand is that you're
opposed to this bill because you but you
first you said you were all big for
competitive Marketplace and competition
is good if you have that right why
shouldn't the on premise licenses also
have the same right that you already
have thank you for your question uh Mr
chairman uh I agree 100% in a
competitive
Marketplace how however the pandemic has
created what I'd call extraordinary
circumstances where the market had to
change to provide relief on a temporary
basis and that's an artificial
Marketplace and we're comfortable with
that however to take that and now expand
it once the marketplace returns to
competition we don't believe that this
is
necessarily uh something that is really
even going to be
beneficial for the restaurant
industry okay well they could be the
judge of that but well no I and I the
reason I put that is nobody's even
identified in the restaurant industry
how valuable that has been for them in
terms of their sales and and and um and
hasn't they haven't tracked and said you
know GE on an average of 10 restaurants
we've seen an increase of you know wine
and beer sales x
amount right well and and vice versa I
have not seen any retailer really
promoting the fact that they would
deliver beer and wine to to Consumers
even though they do have the right to do
it um so we just because we made it it
because it's legal doesn't mean we we're
g make a judgment about whether the
marketplace is ready or wants this
um I it's true the legislature uh is
dealing with this only because it the
because of what happened with the with
the the governor's orders but we can
assume and I think your point is well
taken this we got to assume this is
going to be gone you know a year from
now this is all going to be a distant
memory and so when we get to that place
the question then is um is you know
since we already allow uh on you know
off premise licensees such as yourself
to distribute to sell and deliver
alcohol why shouldn't we also do that
for on premise licenses a year from now
or going forward right you know and you
know I think it's you know it's you know
the the marketplace is going to change
and evolve and we're not certain what
that really is going to look like yet
post pandemic and and I believe
that you know the restaurants chose to
get permitted as on premise consumption
and
lenses and you know that's what they
they got and we took the path of
providing off preference off- premise uh
permitting and licenses to sell for
off-site uh
consumption so in terms of you know the
state determining these different permit
categories ories um is now starting to
blur those permit
categories and you know I think that's
worthwhile it's up for worthwhile
discussion I think and particularly as
it relates to what the true need is
going to be come post pandemic fair
enough um and I and I would say this is
it somewhat selfishly this next question
but I would hope you could help me out
um I want to know where there is an on
premise lency excuse me off- premise
liccy in New Hampshire that actually is
delivering I don't have that at the top
of my fingertips but I'll I can cirle
back see that I'd love to see that
because my instacart you know from it
doesn't because they're a third party
they can't do it so for my handers I'd
love to be order some beer along with my
so it be uh and I know there's drizzle
is out there in other states drizzle
drizzle but if anything you can do to
help me out on that one I really would
appreciate that and I'm sure other
people would be interested to know who
who was actually delivering great thank
you very much for your testimony is
there any other questions from the
committee all right seeing none is there
any attendee who would like to uh weigh
in
okay seeing nobody uh we will close the
public hearing on House Bill 17 oh yeah
one last thing it appears that this uh
section I was very concerned about um is
uh in the current statue in the Statue
we're working in and that uh um as in as
interpreted by one of the lobbyists
who's Johnny on the spot um is that what
they did was instead of just adding it
to all be one paragraph they decided to
break it up into two sections of of the
statute so even though it says repeal
and reenacted is it is nothing is
changed the only thing it's reenacting
is that it's just moved it in where it
was located in the current
statute and with that I will close the
public hearing and uh and we all you all
get this but uh there were 20 in support
and four posts and one neutral so once
you all get that you have that anyways
all right good we'll close the public
hearing and uh so next up is that we
have an exec session at
1:5 okay any other questions from the
committee members any before we recess
for
lunch
okay for you um Mr chairman are you all
set with that um is that that what you
were talking what the question last page
of the amendment okay is that your same
interpretation did you get a chance to
look at it I would be happy to do a
quick comparison of the text I'm sure
whoever gave you that information would
given you the Henry would never steer me
wrong you would not I I so okay all
right thank you all very much and we'll
see you at
1:15
so Pam I was just thinking that if
there's nobody in the committee room um
I can certainly from my computer mute
the committee room and that way I don't
have to hear that fan when it's the only
problem with that is the only way to
unmute it is to physically go down into
the room and so if um representative
Osborne comes again for the exec session
I'd have to run down or else I could
call out to him to to unmute it or you
could call out to him I just it says uh
ask unmute oh I see whoops did I just do
that did I just mute it not you muted it
and and that's okay it's not um you know
there's there's a solution to it it's
not the end of the world but that's why
as long as it's quiet there I like to
leave it unmuted because you know when
he showed up last week I didn't even see
him I didn't because he was off to the
side and right so you know it was great
that it was all like if he had walked
into the room it had been muted and he
had started talking you know he might
have been upset that nobody could hear
him and or wondered what was going on
well that's what he did well he did he
did that he text me and says you know
can't you fix the microphone in
here so that's it's not a you know it's
not a insolvable problem but that's the
the reason okay well I did create the
problem so yes are you there are you are
you at the state house or are you in the
at home yeah I'm at the state house so I
can run down there it's fine I'll run
down there at 110 and just um unmute it
just just in case he shows up so we
don't have an
awkward might as well go ahead and
unmute it that I shouldn't have done
that that was no no it's fine it's fine
I didn't know that I could I that if I
muted it that I couldn't unmute it that
I had to rely on that but learn
something new every day I know
you're in Zoom world all right I will
post the um the lunch notice in a sec
okay perfect
thanks
oh
Pam I didn't know if you knew you were
not
muted this is
chrisy thank you I appreciate
it
representative
gon
yes ma'am is it true you teach
meteorology I do uh I I I'm not teaching
this semester they didn't have a any
sections
available um they've been U reducing
sections and you know they've had some
declining enrollment stuff like that so
being a teaching lecture not full-time
faculty uh I get second pickings but uh
but I do teach meteorology I also teach
physical science and when I get get a
chance I also get to teach college
algebra and I love all of it good
excellent is that is that your main job
teaching uh actually I just started uh
year before last uh at teaching I've
been wanting to for for a long time I
have a friend who's a professor back in
back in Oklahoma and he he told me I
just need to do it he he gave me the
references and and uh twisted my arm he
said I can hire you if you'll move back
to Oklahoma and I said well I kind of
like New Hampshire so I'm going to stay
right where I'm at and see what Plymouth
state will do for me so I I just went
there talked to him and got hired on I
love it well hopefully next year we'll
be back to normal I hope so too I I
thoroughly enjoy teaching but I hate the
uh the zoom method I I am a one-on-one
in the classroom kind of person
so good
good
for
e
all right hour being
11:5 and
um
[Music]
here
okay anybody in the committee
room no I don't believe so I was there
just a minute ago and um unmuted the
machine just in case right and then then
I see papers on a table there yeah we
distribute that's where we put all the
copies of the
bills might show up so that's that was
us it's not a person so so I am getting
bombarded P people asking for amendments
a copy of
amendments um and normally they would
just walk into the committee they would
contact uh Carrie and have that and she
would take care of it so I I'm I'm a
little yeah well if if Carrie has I mean
Carrie has a lot of amendments and if
they've been sent in she has them and
she can send them to people I know but
they I guess people don't know Carri
exists or something but so they're
asking me for copies of amendments which
is you could forward those on to her
that's my wife says delegate delegate
forward forward the effort for me to do
that yeah I say I could just forward it
to her
so excuse me excuse me do as as a as a
freshman legislate do we have to request
amendments so yes so if well let me put
this way so if there's several different
kinds of process for Amendment so let's
say you were um
here in the committee and we're
executing a bill okay uh we would not
vote on a bill unless everybody has the
amendment in their hands okay and
normally we want to get them out so what
happens is but General is that if you
were a
lobbyist or an interested Citizen and
you you know there's a there's an
amendment you would normally call 3369
and get the committee office and carry
with take their information and then she
would send them the copy of the am or do
that okay let alone it's in the file so
that someone could come in and say can I
see a copy of the me it's in the file so
but because she's not there we're not
there then so everybody just says well
next best thing let's I'll contact the
chairman and have him send it to me and
and that's that's what I'm I'm my little
frustration about how we've got to you
know get these amendments out anytime a
person who's testifying is going to
bring like for repr MC Williams she she
went and just sent it to all of us to
our emails and if someone didn't get it
that means it's probably sitting in
their junk file um or you know or their
you know spam file so I don't know you
know but normally what you should be
doing is that if you're going to testify
or if you have an amendment for the bill
you want to go online to the the house
you know page where you say you want to
speak you know or not speak but that PL
that's where you can upload that
Amendment and that would then be sent to
all of us
automatically well thank you for the the
clarification that um in normal times
you I don't know how this is going to
work out now but in normal times in any
governing body I've ever been a part of
the members of the committee of the
governing body are presented with the
amendment in writing before they
consider the
amendment um and and they AR responsible
for going around and searching for it
themselves yeah right exactly exactly
welcome to New
Hampshire it's we don't have staff and
that kind of stuff so yeah yes yes uh
this is funny um I have an amendment for
the first bill coming up in the exec
that went to you and to Pam I did not
disseminate it to the group did I screw
up
uh it did go actually Pam is the one
that request it for me it's the one that
just changed an to or right yes so I
don't I assumed everybody got it I
didn't send it I don't know did Pam did
you send it to the rest of us no I
wasn't positive you you weren't going to
make further changes to it
okay just the an to the or would it be
totally awful if you were to send it out
right now by email to
everyone my other email computers
downstairs
yeah uh well then we it's the first bill
it is the first bill 312 and it was the
change of an to or which I mentioned um
in
in so not everybody got that then uh so
I guess we won't execute I mean I I I
mean I I mean I could if everybody can't
get it if you know if you can get the
amendment um uh we can exact we'll just
push I just made an assumption that it
would come through you word pam pam
would you mind sending that out to
everyone for me please or shall I do it
if you have it right handy that would be
great I don't because I I'm I'm in the
same boat that John is I can't switch to
my this time well I can't yeah right you
turn computers but I mean yes yeah J I
can find it I you maybe not in the next
30 seconds but I can find it okay thank
you move yes Jane Jane is next yes Jay
yeah um I just emailed um I just emailed
Carrie just to find out if she's in the
loop about amendments I'm I hope I'm not
overstepping my boundaries but she's a
friend of mine so I just you know wanted
to know where where are where are the
amendments Mr chair another another
moment of another moment of levity
before we move on to Serious matters
okay I attended the ncsl webinar for a
new state representatives yesterday I
have to tell you how amused I was at the
council given by colleagues in other
states that we should remember to always
be courteous and kind to uh the members
of our personal
staff I'm still trying to find
mine you have a
drawer in in the office that's your
staff well then of course it's lunchtime
I don't know if you guys got it but I
got a bunch of U uh therapists who
called me and when they realized that
they were calling my cell phone number
they well I'm sorry this is the number
we have I go well that's that's my
number I thought I was getting you're
calling your office and staff and I go
well are you in New Hampshire you you
realize they only pay us 100 bucks a
year you know so all right okay all
right um well we could oh we we don't
have to exec anything today okay so we
can just move on and that's but now we
have all this time certain stuff okay
well we're all right for the next
one all right do we know which one of
these bills have amendments so the only
Bill that um I wanted to pass was going
to be
312 and yes I knew there was an
amendment but I it it never crossed my
mind that not everybody got that
Amendment so at this point
um so we don't know that the others if
the others have amendments or not uh I I
wouldn't be entertaining an amendment i'
I'd be entertaining a different
motion so so
let's you know you know there okay
anyway so the next bill uh executive so
we're 475 which is 120 so 123 so we're
good prohibiting the production of a
driver's license or non driver's picture
identification card as a condition of
conducting certain business so would
anybody like to make an inexpedient uh
legislation motion for me anybody would
like to move itl
uh Mr chair yes I speaking of amendments
I literally just got oh he hasn't even
Jordan oler the prime sponsor on this
hasn't even uh sent the amendment he has
sent the amendment work to OS based on
an email we received from Insurance Auto
Auction
so so you would want to wait until we
see his amendment is that what you're
saying um we can retain it but that
would hold up the bill for oh no we're
not retaining anything at the moment
right now I'm interested
in uh I'll be frank right now I'm
interested in killing all the rest of
rest of these bills so we can
discuss discuss that uh but so I'm
looking I'm looking for someone who's is
willing to make an itl motion if nobody
wants to make an itl motion and um then
and I'll make that motion okay
who is that is that you Chris yes it was
okay all right representative Herbert
second by representative pusk moves uh
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
475 and he's recognized to speak to his
motion well basically if I remember
correctly
uh this was almost a side issue and it
was just it was a complication that
uh
um well yeah we in order to do the
business you you know you couldn't um I
can't remember exactly what it was but
the driver's license or non- driver's
picture identification card is a
condition of conducting conducting
certain businesses and it sounded to me
as though um uh it was unnecessary in
other words why did why what are we
doing here and he didn't have a he
didn't have a good answer for me anyway
and
so if I could step in um we do have a
letter from um New Hampshire fishing
game that it would be a real problem for
hunting licenses I did I was about to
mention that okay we also have one about
the age 65 and over free entry into the
Spate Parks right uh which was which uh
would be against we senior
citizens yeah
and and I uh and I as I stated publicly
when I when we had the hearing is that I
do take I do require renters to uh when
they when they book with me to send them
copy of their uh driver's license and
and a is to make sure that they really
are you know over 30 which is what we
require but B is that it helpful for me
to make sure that they really are fine
upstanding citizens and I should not
worry about them Runing to my house if
they're driver's license and the Trek
number and and and the contract they
sign and the check they sign all have
the same address so I know there's
nothing flaky going on so okay uh uh
representative Aon is the next one of
his hand up yes representative Aon uh so
I don't agree with iing the bill and the
reason is that the underlying problem
that the bill is attempting to deal with
is lots of other people storing your a
photoc copy or scan of your driver's
license and then um having the
information get out there somehow and
having um serious identity theft
problems and not having any way of being
able to track it down and find out who
was was was careless with your
information um the problem that the the
the bill attempts to deal with is to try
to put a stop to businesses
essentially U either sharing your
information or keeping your information
in a way that it's not secure and as I
read it the Bill's intend is to Simply
require that a business have a policy on
making sure that your private
information doesn't get out um since the
voters voted I think 89% in favor of
that uh constitutional amendment in
favor of uh protection of privacy um
I'll be voting against the itl and in
favor of retaining the bill and letting
the prime sponsor
uh um come up with his exemption on this
one
issue representative M
Meier uh thank you chairman I you know
just you know unfortunately I uh I take
my car in to get repaired way way too
much and they give me a laner call Car
how am I gonna get a laner car without
showing my
license it's just not g to happen and
then they know I'm gonna come in again
so they do retain it um you know
unfortunately that's the way they do the
business and I can't see how they would
do it any other way thank
you okay any more discussion on the
motion of inexpedient to legisl
seeing none uh the clerk will call the
role Mr chair who was the second on that
motion uh representative pusc okay thank
you and do we all need to be seen on our
videos yes so Tina you need to turn your
computer on and Max you need to turn
your computer on so we can see your
smiling
faces nice
teeth had mine cleaned
yesterday
getting really daring you went on you
went to had your teeth clean when I did
well wait so max are you turning your
camera
on there we go perfect okay uh the clerk
will call the role an inexpedient to
legislate right just catching up
here okay uh representative John pusk
yes representative Jason
Osborne
uh Representative Keith Ammon that's me
yes representative Max Abramson
no representative Bonnie
ham
yes representative Joseph
too he's not
here representative jeffre gon
yes representative Dawn Johnson
yes representative Paul
Terry yes
yes representative chrisy Bartlett
yes representative Richard Abel
yes representative Christopher Herbert
yes representative Constance van hton
yes do you prefer Connie or Constance
you probably should skip the first name
just say representative in their last
representative Fargo yes representative
Weston yes representative
belu yes representative Burrows yes
representative melier yes and
representative hunt
yes all right the uh vote is looks like
16 to one okay
uh Max are are you okay with putting
this on the consent calendar or would
you like this to be on the regular
calendar uh you're
muted back on mute I I have no objection
I'd like to write a Minority Report if
that's all right uh then you has to be
on the regular calendar okay so uh that
leave it on the regular calendar and
there would be a a Minority Report all
right next up may I ask um I'm sorry Mr
chair um I do I owe you a Minority
Report from last week can you give me a
date of when I've got to have that into
you
uh uh well it's not an early that that
was the yeah that was the statement the
statements bill right did you did The
Minority Report on this right right Mr
chair I believe it was the paper
statements whatever paper statements
yeah that was an early bill so yeah I
got to get that right away okay I'll
give it to you today okay question for
the sure send a form for the majority
report just no just write out the report
and email it to me at The Prodigy
address
yes yes the uh the motion for the
minority uh position can't be retain is
that correct it has to be correct so max
your motion is going to be ought to pass
with an amendment or is your motion
going to be ought to
pass I'll just say ought to pass even
though okay I mean we I think we'd have
to introduce an this is the first time
I've ever heard that uh we can't uh
support a motion to retain so what
happened was is the the I have to admit
to you that I was a little cut off guard
too interim study is a prevailing motion
but you can only use the interim study
in the second year of the banum session
so in the first year the retaining is
what's holding on to a bill and um and
so no you can't use that as a mo motion
and that and I always knew that but like
I say I when retaining was invented um
uh it originally was something the chair
could just do the chair could say my
sense is we're not this bill is not
ready for prime time so I I I decided
I'm going to retain it but they took
that away and say now they have a vote
so I it's a little disconcerting but at
this point the process is um you would
have to you know if you went let's say
let's say for instance you went back to
the sponsor he got you an
amendment you can have that Amendment
put in the calendar so you can make a
motion about to pass as
amended I know that that's kind of
bizarre if you think something should
just be held on to you should be able to
make that motion and that's what we're
we're behind seeing a lot of that this
session you have to convince the
committee of that motion at this point
that you got to convince us that we all
agree to retain it but I don't I didn't
think there was a there was a lot of
momentum for that position so okay so at
this point your the minority motion will
be uh ought to pass all right are we
ready Mr chairman I just want to
interject briefly to say that the
amendment to House Bill 312 has been um
sent out to everybody so I I understand
that you're you can't um all access it
right now through your email but it is
in your email boxes Thank you Pam okay
perfect
so all right so what's the next one
um uh one 109 109 relative referral of
debts for collection anybody would like
to make the motion on that one
representative Johnson I make the motion
for itl itl second by representative
pusk uh and and representative Johnson's
recognized to speak to her
motion okay I had
help
um this bill requires creditors to
affirm notice to a consumer two weeks
before a bill on the service which may
be sent to a collections it is really
hard to notify someone if they are no
longer at the address that you have on
file um I think it's going to cost um
many businesses more money than than it
needs to um be and I think it honestly
is it's time consuming and most debt
collectors have more of ability to find
these people and most of these people
already know they owe the money they're
just avoiding it and so to have a two
weeks notice before they get sent to
collections I think is a waste of
time okay any more discussion on the
motion of inexpedient to
legislate seeing none uh uh the clerk
will call the role on inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
475 you mean House Bill 109 yeah I'm
sorry went
backwards okay we aren't all on video
right now okay so uh there we go all
right thank you thank you for joining
okay motion as itl on 109 109 sorry yes
uh okay representative pusk
yes representative
Osborne representative Ammon yes
representative Abramson
hi representative ham yes representative
D
Palma representative G gon
yes representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes representative
Bartlett yes representative Abel
no representive
Herbert representative
Herbert Chris you're
muted
yes representative H van Halton
yes representative Fargo yes yes
representative Weston yes representative
bellu yes representative buros
yes representative melier
yes all
right and yes I'm sorry representative
hun yes all right so 16 to1 16 to1 uh
Rich are you okay with putting this on
the consent calendar
uh yes that's fine okay so all those in
favor of placing on the consent consent
Calendar please say I I those
opposed so move theam
okay all right next is House Bill 313
relative to property restrictions on
certain amateur radio
antennas who would like to make the
motion representative pusk I move itl
representative pusk uh seconded by uh
I'll second it who's that Christie
Bartlett representative Bartlett second
by representative Bartlett news in to
legislate and raised and it we'll get
you in a second um and uh represent uh
sorry um the motion was made by
representative I'm sorry I'm
spacing is recognize to speak to your
motion uh thank you Mr chairman um
although the intent
is
good uh I have serious questions about
the uh personal
property placed on Common Ground it
overrides in my opinion it overrides the
condo association its members and their
rights um so that's what really bothers
me and uh I don't believe that this
thing
uh should pass as an OTP
okay all right uh so representative
Terry you have your hand up uh yes one
moment uh uh yes thank you Mr chairman
um as you may recall or as we may recall
the discussions surrounding this
particular Bill uh I indicated as an
amateur radio operator in the past that
I was uh
sympathetic uh because of all the good
work that they do it didn't seem
reasonable to place any restrictions on
what somebody could do inside their own
domicile um I agreed at your suggestion
to request that that uh representative
Aldrich follow up with you and send you
some photos and begin working on the
issues and questions that were presented
at the time that we entertained the bill
uh sir unless you've heard from him um I
could not I would be sympathetic to to
retaining this but in view of the fact
that he's done nothing to follow up on
my suggestion to him to send you photos
and to address some of those concerns
reluctantly I'm going to have to vote um
itl okay representative
Weston during the discussion there were
also some problems with the legislation
that uh representative Aldrich agreed
would have to be corrected but we've
we've seen no Amendment on
this right so there's there's no sense
in us even thinking about passing it
representative
Aon um I received a lot of so I'll be
supporting retain again um and the
reason is that the bill is uh you know
most of the bill is good and it attempts
to uh resolve a problem where an
antennas are being taken down um
by homeowners associations and because
these amateur radio antennas have been
used a number of times for
emergencies um including I think it what
was it the um we received that email was
it the Enterprise that caught fire and
lo lost uh radio communication and they
had to use uh some type of radio it was
picked up by an amateur homeowner um I
think that because especially living on
the Sea Coast where we're exposed to a
lot of different different types of
disaster and a lot of different types of
danger near the nuclear power plant and
whatnot um that this is something that
benefits the public a lot and although
there may be some wording errors in the
bill um it's worth it's worth it for us
to keep it around and uh either ask the
sponsor to deal with the concerns of
committee members or we can deal with it
ourselves it looks like it's just the
one issue that was causing a
problem I would have to tell I totally
disagree there was one issue this the
problem fundamental problem of this bill
is that um it is someone uh if you if
you buy into a condo you are agreeing to
abide by the condos rules and
regulations um and there was no Towers
being taken
down you made that statement but I I I
don't know any Tower was taken down I
know that that their ham radio operators
might have asked to put up a tower and
they were told no okay but uh the issue
in this case was the was trying to to
flush out that if somebody had the
antenna inside their condo
unit and was running wires around the
ceiling or whatever they did okay is a
condo association doesn't have
regulations about what you do inside
your condos which I'm pretty much sure
most of them don't
then that's not a problem and there is
no problem and the legislation is not
necessary but if you're going to start
using common space or use the outside
abilities or want to do anything and
we're going to have the same question
that comes up with the solar panels no
no yet you should not have bought into a
condo frankly and maybe that's rude of
me to say that but if you really want
one of these things and you really want
to do these things then you need to go
buy you know like me go out buy buy lots
of land and you can do whatever ever you
want with it okay and could the town
zoning but but you know and and and
there could be a town zoning related to
Towers all right and that so uh at the
end of the day that you know the condos
um you know have have the rules and and
for us the legislature to step on their
rules and what their policies are um
seems to me incredibly
inappropriate so and uh welcome
representative Osborne
so are you all set max or do you have
your hands still up do you I I just
wanted to to disagree with the first
thing that you said that it was only
about Towers but um antenna and antenna
support structure are two different
things um and in any case you move into
an area even if as a homeowners
association or a condo association and
the rules are one way and then
afterwards people want to come up they
want to vote in some new role and I
think it's it's kind of unexpected that
someone would insist that you take a
dish or an antenna or something else
down that's outside that you would
normally expect to be an you know like
an like just an antenna it might be a
tall antenna but it's only an antenna I
I think that there's Merit to the bill
it may need a bit of work but you know
that's up to the sponsor in my
opinion fair enough uh representative
gson uh yes sir one thing that this bill
uh does not address is homeowners
associations and only deals with condos
and so uh I know uh representative
Abramson keeps using the term homeowners
associations and this bill actually does
not deal with homeowners association so
just just a minor phraseology there but
they are two different things oh yes
that is correct uh representative Terry
you want to speak again uh yes if it's
in order Mr chairman i' like to move the
question okay please okay any more
discussion well yeah um
I don't see any more discussion on the
motion so all right so the motion is
inexpedient to legislate and the clerk
will call the
role was moved by representative pusk
and seconded by representative partlet
correct correct okay call on the
role representative pusk
yes representative Osborne
yes representative Ammon yes
representative Abramson
no representative ham
yes representative
dama he's still not here representative
gon yes representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes representative
Bartlett yes representative Abel yes
representative Herbert yes
representative van hton yes
representative Fargo
yes representative Weston
yes representative
billu
yes representative buroughs
yes representative
melier yes representative hunt
yes okay that's 17
one one um representative Aon do you
want to write a Minority Report or do
you want to uh are you okay with putting
this on the consent calendar I think
that this is fine for consent okay all
those in favor of pring this bill on the
consent Calendar please say I I and
those
opposed so moved
unanimously
okay all right house bill 166 rela to
safety requirements for pools on
foreclosed residential
property anybody would like to make a
motion on that
one
Johnson okay representative Johnson
second by representative pusk moves
inexpedient to legislate representative
Johnson's recognized this speak for a
motion so the biggest thing on this one
was most of the they already
have pieces in the
associations where they have to already
do this so I see no point in making it a
law or an RSA to do it when they're
already doing it I think we have no
reason to do
it right so um
theoretically every pool has got a fence
around it anyways right and B is that
the mortgage companies are required by
Fanny May
to cover it okay representative burrow
you recognized to speak to the motion of
itl um yes thank you for for letting me
um speak um I actually am in favor of
passing this bill for one reason um I I
um and that is protecting children um I
lived down the street from a house with
a pool um that was not fenced um and
that was empty for two years and I can
tell you it was a magnet for every child
in the neighborhood and Beyond so for
that reason um I support passing it even
to if it's to save one child's
life okay any other discussion on the
motion of inexpedient to
legislate see none the clerk will call
the
role you're you're uh muted
Keith don't have enough hands here
um motion was made by Johnson
representative Johnson and seconded by
representative patus
correct I'm just repeating that so I get
it right for
the okay uh representative pusk yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Ammon yes representative
Abramson I representative ham yes
representative dama
still not here representative gson yes
representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes representative
Bartlett
no representative Abel
no representative Herbert
no sorry I don't know why my phone's
ring representative van hton
no representative
Fargo I didn't hear you Tina you're
you're you're
muted sorry
no representative Weston
no Representative belu
no representative Burrows
now representative melier
no representative
hunts
yes so that is nine to nine the motion
fails right okay the motion
fails uh you guys want to retain it I
guess for those who voted no I would I
would support pass I'm asking someone
who who voted voted uh
to uh no on the pre previous motion is
anybody there willing
to I
would doing that Mr chair yes thank you
I'd like to make a motion to retain okay
good I'll second that
motion
chman I'm sorry who was that Chris
melier Maier Sor okay so representative
Bartlett second by representative melier
moves to retain um House
Bill
166 is there any discussion on the
motion information Mr chair yes
represent hypothetical here but what
what happens in a case where all motions
fail uh that that is that that's almost
catastrophic uh that is that if a motion
fails if we can't if we can't get any
motion to pass then it has to leave the
committee
and go to the house floor with no
recommendation and prevailing motion
will be up to
pass so we don't ever want to be in that
place okay so the motion is to
retain represent
Amon yep they gave me lots of forms to
fill out
here
one
second so I need another okay I'm
sorry this is the first experience with
a failed motion
yeah
now whose phone is ringing all this time
it's mine I I I have to have my I I put
it out into the hallway
there can you take it off the
hook I threw mine into the bathroom into
the bedroom the other day I couldn't get
it to stop and meanwhile I've gotten
three voicemails and I'm sure all these
calls are about that mental health Bill
about the clawback bill
yeah
you ready Keith almost almost sorry
about
this looks like I saved over my uh
template so I have to start over
here the motion is to retain motion is
to
retain Representative pusk
no representative
Osborne no whose music is that that's
mine I have to have the sound on to
answer the
question uh
yes representative Osborne you vote
yeser
rtin
correct representative Ammon
no representative Abramson
hi representative
[Music]
ham representative ham
yes representative
theama represent gon yes representative
Johnson yes representative Terry
yes representative
Bartlett sorry yes representative Abel
Herbert yes representative van hton yes
representative far
[Music]
yes representative Weston
yes representative bellu Excuse me yes
representative Burrows yes
representative melier yes representative
hunt
yes okay that's
16-2
okay uh okay the last one is uh House
Bill 473 establishing a renters
insurance notification
requirement who would like to make a
motion on that
one johon
itl yes Mr chairman I'll second the
motion to itl okay represent
representative gson thank you Johnson
second representative gson moves
inexpedient to
legislate and uh the rec representative
Johnson your ni to speak to your motion
yes this bill this bill would require
landlords to include resident
residential rental agreements for more
than one month a statement that informs
the renters that the landlord insurance
does not cover the attendant's
belongings with a loss of damage that
the landlord recommends that the tenant
purchase rent
insurance this bill will not prevent the
harm that is intended to prude it does
not address a situation where there is
no renters
agreements uh just because there is a
line in the lease doesn't not mean that
the tenant is going to um read the lease
or understand it um the requirements
create unnecessary legal liability to
the landlord it is a trap for small um
form landlords the burden of teaching
about insurance belongs on the
individual not on landlord Lords no
insurance requirement for automobiles
nor do dealers have to go through these
kind of um situations so why should
landlords lastly it is not the
government's place to dictate what
should be in a um Private Business
contract there are many far there are
also way too many far-reaching
unintended consequences of this
bill okay uh representative gson your
first
first uh I have nothing additional to
add to it just that the uh this is
unnecessary uh addition of of
legislation it's something so simple
that it's a there's no need to to
legislate something like this
representative Bartlett thank you Mr
chair um we heard so much testimony I
mean I'm I'm kind of surprised that that
uh the committee is taking um the
opposite view of your parties uh
sponsors um we heard lots of testimony
about renters in the state that do not
understand how Insurance works there was
another fire last night um yesterday in
Raymond um a number of the tenants there
have no insurance um the towns will be
having to step in Red Cross needs to
step in um though I agree that people
should know this there are too many that
don't um and my motion
um I would oppose this motion I'd like
to see it retained and amended um as it
was last year this bill didn't come in
exactly the way we had um um had amended
it last year so um if if the motion to
kill it um does not pass I would like to
make another motion okay thank you
representative van hunon and hton excuse
me thank you Mr chair um well I
definitely agree that this is an educ
issue and that we need to educate young
people I do feel that if this is in
legislation it will be a step toward
that kind of education it will become
more broadly known and it will help
young people particularly going into
their first department or their first uh
lease agreement to uh to understand this
and to take care of themselves we've
seen the fires that are devastating the
front page of the union leader today uh
shows the Rond fire to which
representative bartl alluded and um
although as I said I do understand the
idea that it's an education component we
need to Foster making that education go
forward and therefore I would agree that
OTP would be the better option thank
you okay uh representative M um thank
you Mr chairman I I strongly believe
that this uh should be added to a lease
agreement it's just a
notification uh it's very very simple it
doesn't cause the the landlord any
liability I'm a real estate AG
and if you work with a ton of of
disclosure statements and and purchase
and sale agreements uh it goes Way
Beyond this in making people sure that
they understand exactly what they're
getting into this is no different than
that it's a very very simple way for the
landlord to Simply say hey look by the
way uh you might want to ensure your
property because I don't ensure it it's
it's so simple I can't believe that
anybody would not support this thank
you well I'll tell you um it's actually
I think it's so simple that we don't
want to do this um you know frankly um
if if the simple question is do you
really think the landlord's going to pay
insurance you know pay for your
insurance uh did the landlord ask you
what your value the contents is worth
and I mean most people um don't even
read the lease all right they they're
just so happy to get the proper they
move in the lease what I didn't like is
the unattended consequences of with a
landlord finds out that we have passed
legislation that says that anytime you
sign a new lease you have this the
landlord is now going to say is well I
don't want to give a lease then if I
don't do I do I do everything verbal I
don't want to do this so I think that
would do a disservice to renters to not
get a written lease and know what
exactly what they should have and
shouldn't you know what's in the lease
and what's and it basically is um to me
passing this legislation is to tell
landlords uh well this is just the
beginning and who knows what else we're
going to add into the statute that
you're G now don't sign a lease don't
give a lease so you don't have to be
worried about whether you are uh whether
you're in or not you know whether you
have this thing Canna happen to you and
worse of it is is that it doesn't even
clear if I what happens if you don't put
it in the lease so the idea that we're
passing legis oh let just speak the that
we let you put something into the lease
that maybe may or may not have any
consequences to it that's supposed to
inform people things um I I just think
that that is much better uh communicated
by a real estate agent whoever help them
find that find that apartment to let
them know by the way uh I know I might
be stating the obvious but you you're
the landlord's insurance is covering the
building ain't covering your property so
I I think it's just a misuse of
government to be you know forcing into
documents that is uh purely educational
I guess it's the way it's phrased So
yeah thank you thank Mr hump but I I I I
couldn't disagree with you more if if
you have a lease agreement and you tell
the the uh uh your your tenants that you
should read this and you've got to check
this off you've got to initial this my
God the landlord is totally free and
clear you've you've accepted the tenant
has accepted the liability I I think
landlords would love this or they should
let's put it that way thank you then
they should do it on their own they
don't need to be told told to do it okay
uh so I see some more hands up
representative Johnson did
you I wasn't sure if I was muted or not
dogs keep working so basically you're
trying to tell landlords how to run
their business it's it's it's not fair
government has no right to tell a
business bus how to run their business
and what to put in their lease it's
their up it's their it's their
lease also learn to educate themselves
and have their parents and those around
them educate
them and
simple I I'm I'm muting you Chris we can
hear your
laugh okay represented
gon I think this becomes a a stepping
stone it's it's a nice to have kind of
thing uh to to be able to sit down with
your with your tenant and explain to
them that my uh my homeowners policy
does not cover your your household goods
uh that you should get uh renters
insurance I know in places where we
rented that was just explained to us and
it was never necessarily a part of any
lease agreement so it's a nice thing to
have uh but when you put it down this
this starts the process well now because
not enough people are getting the the
clue that they need to get their own and
they may choose not to get the insurance
policy even after it being in the lease
you now it's required that you have a
little line at them kind of like you're
as a as a real estate agent you have all
those disclosures uh well you have to
sign those disclosures and you have to
show as both the agent uh that you
showed those disclosures to your your
client uh they have to sign that and
then you have to sign it as the agent as
well and that's all presented in your
packet of information so the next step
is now that the landlord has to actually
have the tenant acknowledge uh in the
lease that that you explained that
portion then what other portions of the
lease and it just begins to snowball
next thing you know the landlord is
required to carry a renters policy in
his lease and yes it it starts with with
with education but then it becomes a man
a mandate of some kind of a purchase so
I I love the idea of telling people I
told my son he has to have his own
renters insurance and he rents from me
and so he's on his own if he chooses not
to my my insurance doesn't cover his
Goods um but uh uh education is good but
this is not
necessary represent van
hton little bit of delay there trying
you get your hands up yeah okay she took
her hand back down okay and remember M
you're all set okay is there any just
more discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to legisl seeing none the
clerk will call the
role and just refresh my memory who made
the motion who seconded uh I believe it
was representative Johnson in the motion
representative gson uh that's correct
second the motion
yes you repeat the motion
please is inexpedient to
legislate representative pusk
yes representative Osborne yes
representative Ammon yes representative
abson hi representative ham yes
representative dama representative gon
yes representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes representative
Bartlet
no representative
Abel
representative
able you just muted you were unmuted
Rich I'm sorry uh no representative
Herbert no representative van hton
no representative
Fargo
Tina sorry
no representative Weston
no Representative belu no Representative
buros
no Representative melier no
representative
hunt
yes that is nine to n the motion
fails okay representative Bartlett
seconded by representative maer Mo's
retain of uh he
Bill
473 thank you Mr chair um yes I'd like
to make the motion to retain um I will
bring forth a an amendment and we can
discuss this in September and next
January right fair enough any more
discussion on the motion of
retaining seeing none the house will uh
the clerk will call the rooll I just
need a
second
representative
pusk uh
yes representative
Osborne
yes representative Ammon yes
representative Abramson no
representative ham
yes representative dama representative
gon yes representative Johnson yes
representative Terry yes representative
Bartlett
yes representative Abel yes
representative Herbert yes
representative van hton yes
representative
Fargo yes representative ative Weston
yes representative Bill U yes
representative Burrows yes
representative melier yes representative
hunt yes vot is 17 to
one okay uh that's that's it for the
exact session so we'll move out of the
exact session and we'll start our public
hearing and our first bill is uh House
Bill 416 allowing hobby distillation of
Liquors and
I'm Mr chair I have to run over and um
testifying another bill and then I'll be
right back fair enough I'm not sure how
to do this but okay so uh so anyone who
would like to speak on this bill would
you please just raise your hand so I can
move you over
okay there's Scott
great the
panelist Scott
Wallace
right so apologize for for the delay
Scott and welcome to
the
thank oh
my okay everybody please remute thank
you okay thank you chair hunt members of
the committee um House Bill 416 would uh
amend RSA 175 B1 to allow the hobby
distillation of liquor as you know uh
home brew and home making of wine just
became lawful in New Hampshire in 2012
or so um the natural progression of the
hobby uh making wine and beer um is that
you'd like to at some point in time
perhaps make some brandy or some bourbon
um this bill would
allow those of us that make our own wine
and beer to do so but only from the
already limited quantity of wine or beer
that we can already
produce um this is not moonshining this
is more of a craft activity on a very
small scale uh if you were to spend the
time and produce the maximum amount of
wine or bear you could produce presently
you would produce at best possibly 20
gallons uh in an annual basis which is a
tremendous amount of
work um presently Missouri Maine
Massachusetts Michigan Alaska Ohio and
Rhode Island allow this although it is
still prohibited federally um currently
the ttb or the the the alcohol tax arm
of the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms does not enforce the small
scale the hobbyists at this point in
time they target the uh the Moonshiners
that are actually turning a profit doing
this um most of the people that are
involved in this activity are as I said
Artisans uh very small scale using
stainless steel and electrified
equipment so there's virtually no risk
of fire no risk of lead poisoning those
are that's in the old Backwoods days uh
before leadfree Silver solder was um the
requirement in plumbing code throughout
the
country
um that's where're at at this point in
time hopefully uh we can get a little
traction on this this year um yes it's
still uh prohibited federally but
passage of this would allow New
Hampshire to be right on board um when
this becomes lawful at the federal level
and with that it be more than Happ to
take any
questions and I cannot hear you chairman
hun okay representative par thank
you thanks very much Mr chair um would
you be able to help us
remember the bill that was brought forth
in last the last term didn't this come
forward
earlier yes uh I have um brought this
bill forward previous in previous
sessions and I may I ask another
question forther question may inquire
thank you
um I don't know much about distilling
Liquors I have to admit that but I think
some of the concerns we had was
regarding poisoning and I don't believe
it was lead poisoning that we were
worried about we're worried about the
alcohol content and how hobbyists can
control that would you be able to answer
that question yes uh thank you for the
question it's a very good question um
hobbyist and Artisan distillers are
distinctly different from Mass producers
and we only keep uh the very best um
what they call the hearts of the of the
production run um
making liquor or distilling Al uh
distilling wine or wash or beer into
into an alcohol um it's not much
different to makeing jam in that when
you start the process the first bit uh
of material that comes from the still uh
contains the tpin and the the nasty bits
if you will that have the uh the
poisonous uh type of alcohol that comes
out first um in a large for-profit
Enterprise um those distillers are going
to keep the maximum amount of material
that they can so they get the maximum
yield on their products The Artisans we
do it a little bit differently so say
from a you know a small still you got a
a five gallon charge in there you might
you might produce a gallon and a half of
what you of a RI when when when it
starts producing it's going to to only
run for a little bit of time and you
only keep the very best which is the the
middle portion of the run if you will um
by I don't I don't know what the Federal
Regulations are but typically on a five
gallon still you're going to produce
about a half a cup of harmful product
that comes out first at the lower
temperatures once this still gets up to
I believe the temperatures 168 or 170
degrees that's all good clean alcohol at
that point in time
so typically the uh The Artisans
discard probably a half a gallon
initially so you're certain to get all
of those bad products out and you keep
just the best and you discard the tail
ends of it as
well ask another question further
question man inquire thank you Mr chair
so how would a let's say a firsttime
hobbyist who isn't getting coached is
just reading a recipe book presumably
how would they know how much of the
poisonous product to
discard excellent question and uh from
everything that I have read uh over the
last decade or more years um every
single recipe every book that I've read
on the subject that is the very very
beginning uh in the preface uh
and just to make you aware of the risks
of that and uh and there's typically a
chart as to the scale of your still
how much you should discard and most
people discard twice that amount from
initially just to make sure um also um
as you're producing this you typically
put it in a small containers so that you
can um do your blending just like a a
blended Scotch is going to be made of
all the the best portions or the cuts if
you will from the at the distilling
process um those that first um half cup
or so you probably wouldn't drink it
just because of the odor coming from it
um it smells like Crossing rubbing
alcohol and nail polish I wouldn't drink
anyway but that's
okay so I'm sorry may ask you one more
question the nose is most
unpalatable uh I don't think anybody
would drink it just because of the uh uh
the fumes coming off of it thank you Mas
one more question sure and I'm sorry
this is serious for me um sure I'm
because I'm not a a whiskey offici
andado I did go to a whiskey tasting in
in in Scotland and decided I was not
going to do it again but um but my
concern is if this is if these are
hobbyists so they don't sell it but the
feds are still outlawing it because
those who do sell who is are for-profit
distillers have a lot of regulations on
them how how do we we as a
state know that these distillers can
test their product not to be
poisonous that that's a good question I
don't know that there's any test per se
uh short of doing sometime of some type
of chromatography or you need some type
of test equipment to do that um and not
knowing the process uh for example that
there's multiple distilleries at like in
lenary I think uh Jenkins is over there
so that's an excellent question I'm not
sure how we would be able to um regulate
that okay okay thank you very
much okay representative
mcleer yes thank you representative hunt
how much in theory could an artisan how
much proof could they obtain in theory
could they obtain
you know what grain alcohol
has thank you for the question
representative that's that's a good
question that is a function of the type
of still that they're operating and how
many times the product is distilled um I
presume you might have seen on a uh you
know on a high-end uh scotch or vodka
bottle it might say triple distilled um
what that process is is just like it
sounds it goes through the still one
time again and on a third pass each time
you concentrate the alcohol further um
you know as far as hobbyist typically
the type of Stills that they have I
don't think they're going to be able to
attain a you know 190 proof grain
alcohol something like that
that's typical laboratory or medical
grade stuff uh but certainly you know
you know 140 150 is definitely
attainable
wow representative Burrows
yes thank for thank you for taking my
question um I was reading that methanol
is the greatest danger um for home
distillers but that it's produced in
such a minuscule amount as to not to be
um worrisome is that is that
correct yes that is my understanding and
the the boil off point for the the wood
alcohols of the methanol if you will is
at the lower end of the um the
temperature scale uh around 130 to 140
de so as such um your your acetones your
your your um your wood alcohols your
tpin those burn boil off first and are
what we call the heads or the the
initial output of the still and that is
all we
discarded yep and representative Weston
thank you for taking my question
representative Wallace um as I
understand it there's no uh license
required for this right yes that is
correct followup further question me
inquire so uh if there own license how
is it monitored how will the department
the the the alcohol regulation
Department know how to who to check up
on uh thank you for the question and
it's an excellent question presently um
the home production of wine in beer is
not regulated nor is it taxed
um and as we know through the
fermentation process that is where the
alcohol is produced okay in the wine or
the beer and uh from my knowledge I
don't believe that the New Hampshire
Liquor Commission is going around and
asking if you sending out surveys did
you produce you know 200 gallons of beer
in your home well there's only one
person you can't do
that I don't think it's going to be
regulated like that um and and just to
go a little bit further from a taxation
perspective the the alcohol is produced
at the fermentation level distillation
only concentrates the alcohol so there
really isn't a tax basis it's it's
produced at the fermentation
process okay so Scott just make sure I
understand because my understanding was
that no matter how bad your beer and
wine is no matter what you do you can't
make anything more you can't make any
poison you can you only it's going to
kill some
somebody but you can if you distilled in
other words is a potential that you
could be just distilling something and
fermenting it as you say and and make
something that's poisonous uh but where
it's not true for beer and
wine that is correct to a to an extent
um if you had some type of contamination
in your wine or beer you could certainly
have a very U poisonous uh in a product
that would make you sick but you
probably wouldn't consume it because it'
be so off pallet that you'd either pour
it down the drain or again you could you
know it cost some money to make a batch
of wine or beer you could at least strip
off the alcohol and make some neutral
Spirits if by running it through a
processor of some
sort you probably got a bad stemach EG
yes
but thank you very
much yeah I think we're all thank you uh
and uh we have attorney Moore from The
Liquor Commission
who is
neutral and this your does it work
Aiden can you hear me representative I
can um yes the commission's neutral but
as as was pointed out by previous
speakers uh this is a uh contrary to
Federal
Regulation and um
I know in the past uh when when this
legislation has been brought uh we just
simply pointed it out that it was
against the federal uh regulations for
uh home distilling so we would um just
offer that and if there are any
questions uh we'll be happy to take them
sir well just to play Devil's Advocate
that so is so is growing marijuana and
but evidently the feds don't seem to be
shutting that down
well thank you for your question sir
um and uh I am uh um I'm I'm not a
policy maker so therefore I do not
presume to question the wisdom of those
who do make public policy uh I just
point out that uh the federal government
has chosen to make this process
illegal and uh I would leave it to the
uh members of the committee to determine
if that's something they would like to
continue to follow in New Hampshire or
to choose to go in a different direction
fair enough thank you any questions
representative Herbert has a
question um thank you chairman
hunt and
uh Aiden Mr Moore I know I understand
why you kind of dodged that last
question but the uh the fact is uh
hobbyist which is the word used I guess
in the
legislation um sometimes do have to get
licenses and uh and we had the ham
operators those are that took quite a
bit of learning and and uh time to learn
how to do it and make it work worthwhile
and I noticed the people that were
against the uh the
antennas called them hobbyists as if
it's a nothing kind of deal so um the
idea that you we they can't go in and
give you 10 bucks in order to make uh
liquor or 15 or 20 bucks to go
fish uh tells me that the state is well
capable of and in its rights to ask for
uh uh some sort of U down payment so
they know who is likely to be uh doing
this and uh I don't have a problem I
don't know I have a problem with doing
it actually where we
but the idea that the state doesn't have
to should not uh you should get a should
not have to get a permit for something
is not uh is is not um always the fact
would you believe would you believe in
my
opinion but
uh sometimes you have to get a license I
I think the uh in the past as as was
pointed out um the legislature has kind
of carved out um um home uh Brewers
people who produce a very small amount
of beer or wine for personal consumption
as an area that they do not want to
regulate and that um um there has not
been a u uh to my knowledge we've never
had a request for an investigation or
any problem associated with that um I
think chairman hunt made a good point
about the the the fact that the still
spirits um is a bit of a different
creature I mean it's still alcoholic
beverages but the now the
regulation uh you know should I guess
the question is should there be
regulation on um you know someone
who how much of the regulation would you
want to apply here uh if you were to to
consider this um and pass it and um to
my knowledge uh the bureau or the
division has not investigated anyone who
has been Manufacturing
uh distilled Spirits at home U we've not
had
complaints um if we had received them we
probably would certainly follow up on
them uh just to investigate uh but there
is uh no allowance for that at the state
level and I'm not sure
um there's a a great deal of benefit to
have a contrary State policy but then
then again that's that's up to the to
the committee to decide whether there's
Merit to that or
not okay any other questions for
attorney
Moore uh seeing none we thank you very
much for your
testimony Mr chairman I think
representative blue may have had her
hand up oh well I didn't see I did I
didn't have the yellow hand up I just
had my hand
up uh yeah this is for thank you Mr
chair uh this is a question for Mr Moore
um could do you have a definition for uh
what a hobby desolation
uh what hobby
is uh not in title 13 no I mean we would
look to the statutes to to describe
the what would be considered a a hobby
would be based on production amounts and
I think that's how the legislature has
choosen chosen to look at this in the
past uh with beverage you know beer and
w is to say it's if you're producing
less than this amount and for personal
consumption then it seems to be a hobby
um and we've been very uh we've been
fine with that approach and it seems to
work out pretty well so
far I'm not sure if that's answering
your question yeah yeah um just a a
followup um Mr Mr
chair um the it in the bill it indic
Ates that the um um Liquors would not be
for sale or sold um Can is there how can
you TR how can you track that as an
enforcer well I think we if if there
were let's put it this way if there were
a hobbyist uh home producer of beer or
wine who decided that they were going to
start selling it um we probably would
hear about it when someone made a
complaint of something type um and and
that probably would exist the same way
with theill Spirits if someone were to
uh make a complaint it would be
investigated and um then if if there was
enough evidence um you know we would
certainly want to advise the citizen
this is against the law you can't do it
and um hopefully they would stop and if
they chose not to stop selling it then
there are other legal remedies of
available as
well uh representative Abel now has a
question yes uh thank you and thank you
Mr Moore um are you
aware uh of there being any problem with
Federal enforcement in the states that
have uh enacted a law of this kind have
you heard of anything of that
nature I have not sir uh I have not
heard of anything like
that no said okay anybody else see none
uh I'll let representative Wallace have
the last
word thank you chairman hunt members of
the committee uh just to follow up with
that question previously asked uh the
hobby distills Association um through
some lobbying efforts we did have a bill
uh going through the Congress couple
sessions back um um it made it through
committee and then things happened it
didn't go any further than that but we
did have a um a definition of a of a
hobby distiller uh in that in that
legislation um and what the uh Congress
had come up with is uh the still could
be not any larger than 16 gallons why 16
gallons well that's the size of a
stainless steel beer cake which is a
preferred vessel for this type of
activity and it also limits the size of
um of the batch if you will um so
hopefully that's some some help and
again the other Provisions were could
not be sold uh you know it could only be
consumed on premise but it also could be
brought to tastings and competitions and
things like that um in the hopes that
perhaps a interesting product might be
brought to Market as a result of a good
performance at one of these get
togethers great thank you very much uh
and and I don't see any attendees hands
up
so I think we're good thanks chairman
thanks to the members of the committee
and uh the members from the uh Liquor
Commission appreciate it okay thank you
and we will close the public hearing um
on
416 and open up the public hearing and
House Bill
403 uh
Growlers all right
and I see representative proud so I will
move him up and I will move you off
Scott and good afternoon representative
proud good afternoon representative hunt
can you hear me yes we can excellent
thank you Mr chairman I Andrew PR
representing Hillsboro County District
37 the towns of Hudson and pelum this
bill would remove the prohibition on
breweries filling growlers from other
breweries most breweries that sell
refillable beer containers called
Growlers include their logo on The
Growler due to RSA 175 colon 2's
prohibition on the misbranding of
alcohol this means that they can only
that only that Brewery can refill that
container however Growlers with No Label
can be found online and you're able to
fill those
anywhere the prohibition on misbranded
alcohol makes perfect sense for a
prepackaged product for Growlers but for
Growlers where the customer selects a
product and watch it watches it being
filled it doesn't keep in mind The
Growler usually only stay stays says the
name of the brewery not the specific
product so it's not even directly
comparable to the labeling on
prepackaged
beer most breweries have a tag they'll
place on The Growler specific specifying
which beer was filled with and the date
limiting the potential for any
confusion this bill would create a new
section RSA 175 colon 2A that states
where the sale in a refillable container
is already authorized the
labeling on The Growler does not have to
match the product in it this would allow
customers to not have to maintain a
fleet of Growers for the breweries they
frequent and encourage visiting new
breweries for takeout without being
forced to buy yet another
Growler thank you for your time and
consideration I'd be happy to answer any
questions Comm may
have
okay represented
Barlett thank you I'm sorry I'm sorry I
was slowing on the uptake again um okay
so it feels like we've got deja vu all
over again here um some of the questions
we've had on this bill in the past is
how would whatever the Brewer is that is
filling this Growler that has no uh that
the label doesn't necessarily match the
brewery what if there's a problem with
that product and there's no way to
trace who which brewery made that
beer thank you for the question um
that's a little bit already of a well a
problem with the product uh brings up a
couple different uh things I'm not sure
what you mean by it either that the The
Growler wasn't filled and therefore
there's a problem with the product
because of resido or The Growler wasn't
clean or there was actually a problem
with the beer um and also as I mentioned
since places do sell Growlers that have
no label whatsoever that's kind of an
already existing problem um of
identifying where it come from and I
think that's why most breweries attach a
a paper tag as they fill the growler so
they know who filled it what it was
filled with because most sell more than
one uh option and often the DAT it was
filled as well and I would look to that
tag to solve the problem you bring up
instead of having the label and The
Growler uh which contains even less
information ask another question Mr TR
for the question me inquire thank you um
yeah you're right you're you know I'm I
I'm alluding to those questions
um we we buy milk in refillable
containers glass jars glass half gallon
containers
and we try to wash them out well before
we bring them back to the dairy however
I certainly see many that are not
cleaned how would
a and but the dairy has to go through a
sanitizing process how would a
brewery deal with an unclean container
because they can't really tell I mean it
may look clean but it's not um when
they're filling it up when somebody
brings that bottle in and asks them to
fill it and then later you find out that
it wasn't clean and does cause a
problem thank you for the question um
well I agree with you that's a problem
and then that's why most breweries do
have a station to wash Growlers before
they fill them it's not really a new
problem created by this bill because
that's a problem with Growlers that have
the label of that Brewery and Growlers
that have the label of the brewery down
the street that's not really a a change
in that caused by this bill but may ask
one more question for question thank you
um thank you for answering question but
this
bill you know specifically does not
address that issue it says with a
beverage that does not match the
labeling on the
container at the direction of the
buyer so they don't have to put the
label on it doesn't have to be clean
the container doesn't have to be clean
but if there is a subsequent problem
tracing it could be an issue do you
agree well I agree with you tracing it
could be an issue I don't think that's a
change in this bill at all because a as
I mentioned today if you bring in a
growler With No Label whatsoever they're
allowed to fill it uh and I think we
have to distinguish what we're talking
about labels what this would this bill
is trying to addess is the pre-printed
labels that are permanently fixed uh
often laser etched in the side of a
glass Growler or metal
Growler the labels or the tags I
mentioned earlier are usually just Paper
Tags that look similar to disposable
luggage tag or key tags they often
attach or or even some just use a p
piece of painters tape and write on it
that they attach as they fill it um and
so while I agree that if there was an
issue that they had to trace it that
would be a challenge that's not really a
challenge made significantly different
by this bill than it is already today
where filling of crowlers is already
authorized by uh the applicable statute
and regulations thank
you so Andrew you know as I remember
reading this bill you know a couple
weeks ago and I meant to get do some
homework on it so make sure I understand
what you're doing because this is
totally different than any Growler Bill
we've ever had before because um first
of all the only person the only ones who
can be filling this is a beverage
manufacturer so this hasn't have nothing
to do with on premise or off- premise
lenses this is simply about filling a
container words I needed to look up what
175 2A is but and this is somewhat
setting up for Aiden to come up is this
is only affecting the beverage
manufacturer or is this some where you
are expecting that you could go into a
um on premise lensey and have them fill
a fill a
container thank you for the question uh
I certainly will not pretend to be uh
the absolute expert on who is currently
allowed to fill a growler I believe it's
currently um manufacturers and also brw
hubs which the brw hubs kind of cross
the line between uh a little bit but
this bill wouldn't change who was
authorized to fill a growler it just
remov moves one restriction that if it
has someone else's name laser etched in
the side of it they're not allowed to
touch it this would remove that
restriction right so what this
perspective is that um is I walk in with
a growler uh with Brand X into a
beverage manufacturer brand
Y and he says uh I I I can't fill that
because it's not my my
bottle um which this legislation says is
well you disregard whose name is on this
this container you're a beverage
manufacturer you can refill a growler I
just want your stuff put in this
Growler and passing this bill will make
that
legal correct that is the intent of this
bill and hopefully what it will do if
passed as is written okay cause when the
issue of Growlers in general why we
haven't really gotten anywhere with grow
is that that is exactly what the
beverage manufacturers don't want to
happen is that it would have the wrong
label on what the product is in other
words that that I would venture to say
you could pass this but have you found
any beverage manufacturers who think
this is a good idea because I would say
the most of them that come to us before
about why they're opposed to Growler are
specifically that is their number one
concern is they don't want the wrong
somebody else's product in their Growler
and vice
versa so uh I have had be um Brewery B
manufacturers tell me they would be
happy to do it in the past whether they
were truly happy or hiding behind the
existing law um yeah I certainly wasn't
uh putting him in front of a hearing to
where I necessarily would know the
difference fair enough all right uh
representative
vo yeah thank you Mr chair
um thank
whoops thank you for taking my question
uh again this is just a followup on uh
representative chairman Hunt's um
comment it would be misrepresentation of
uh product I know that's not the word
but if you give that growler to someone
then they could they may think that
they're drinking you know x uh beer but
they're drinking y beer so I I don't
like this spill at all that's a would
you believe would you
believe uh thank thank you for the
question and um you know that was one of
the reasons why it was limited in the
bill before you to uh only at the
direction of the customer because it is
assumed already that you know people
don't go out and resell Growlers after
they filled them it's usually the person
that got it filled is the one that's
going to be consuming it and hopefully
between that and the fact that pretty
much all I've seen put some sort of
temporary uh tag on it to to tell you
what it is uh there wouldn't be any
misunderstanding of what the person is
drinking that would I I would think
that'd be a rare
event okay representative
ham thank you Mr Speaker um would you
believe that I would have some concerns
about this I know I have friends that um
uh have breweries and to me it it could
um be false advertising somebody comes
in and
buys um buys a a growler full of beer
with such and such a label on it and
they bring it to a party and it sitting
there on the bar or on the table and
everybody's pouring out um uh their
glass of beer and potentially thinking
it came from such and such a brewery and
perhaps just can't wait to go to that
Brewery this beer is so terrific would
you believe I I I think it could be
problematic and I and I would have
questions as to whether um the majority
of the Brewers would be in favor of
this thank you for the question um I
wouldn't consider you know a as someone
who uh drinks beer and and and often
samples what other people bring to
parties that that wouldn't that that
scenario wouldn't make the most sense to
me simply because almost all breweries
have multiple beers that they produce
and offer and off and also are often
changing them over time and so whether
someone did like or didn't like a beer
it would be very unusual even if they
saw the label of Brewery on a container
to not ask which beer it is of the uh
likely several that that uh Brewery
makes before either thinking that they
enjoy it or or don't or don't like it do
or don't want to go that Brewery
and that would trigger the question to
whoever the owner of The Growler were or
they check the tag and that I would hope
would resolve that conflict uh as to the
second part of the question as to
whether a majority of Brewers would be
in favor or not in favor I have not run
a survey of breweries to have any
information on that but I would say that
this bill would not compel breweries to
fill a growler with someone else's label
if they did not want to it would just
remove the state prohibition on them
doing
so okay uh representative
gson yes thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative Prout for uh
answering our questions today
so under this bill if this bill were to
pass would it be possible for someone
else to obtain a growler of one label
with another product in it
or would it only be you could take your
Growler of whatever label to a different
uh refill Place whatever and only you
are the one who would be getting the say
mislabeled product or mismatched product
to
Growler thank
you thank you for the question I believe
the latter scenario is is the correct
answer uh that you would would only be
you taking The Growler to get it filled
and I believe there's already
prohibitions in law against you you know
trying to go take that and resell it
anywhere you know sharing it with other
people that might come over for a visit
uh would certainly be I believe legal
and allowed um but again the person that
got the The Growler filled would be
assumedly present and able to answer any
questions and able to resolve any uh
issues about what is in the container if
those Come Those came up just chair may
follow up just to make sure I I
understand something for the question me
okay so going back to the example of
like the the uh the milk bottles this is
there's not an exchange where you can
take empty bottles back and then you can
pick out other bottles then the the uh
the farm the dairy would then take those
bottles that you returned clean them and
refill them this is you bringing in an
empty container saying please fill this
it just ignore what's on the label and
then you pick it out and you take it
back out out with you at the same
time correct that is my understanding of
how I've seen all breweries work I don't
know of any that have a a swap service
where you uh drop drop one off pick up a
different one it's usually you purchase
up front uh the physical Growler and
that is is yours to keep and there's no
exchanging
it I thank you okay and represent
M uh yes thank you uh chairman um Mr
proud I correct me if I'm wrong but I
I've been a while since I've refilled
The Growler but I if I recall when I get
it refilled or even if I get it filled
up at at the bar and take it with me
they put some sort of the seal on the
top so that uh if I sto by the police it
shows that it hasn't been opened so I
think that that would uh if it was
labeled differently and that seals on
the top I I think that would preclude
there really being
any any problems of uh of what am I
trying to say
uh Federate beer so to speak am I
correct at
that thank you for the question uh I
have seen breweries do that and and you
know as I mentioned earlier I've seen
many use tags that just hang around the
neck of the bottle I've seen some use
essentially painters tape and tape it
right over the cap I do not believe
there's a uniform consistency in that
process uh and uh but I have seen all
breweries in that last couple years do
that uh but it would not it's not
exactly uh as you said a seal that would
uh show proof of whether the bottle had
been opened or not since it had been
filled um and again that wouldn't change
in the positive or the negative by this
bill okay representative pusc uh thank
you Mr Mr chair representative Crow
would you believe that what you are
proposing is the norm in the state of
Pennsylvania yes I would believe that
thank
you really
Pennsylvania I know they feel Growlers
but I don't know if they feel other
people's Growlers I think they have a
state standard Growler they don't have
third party grower at least when I was
in Pennsylvania so representative
Terry I'm not sure this is particularly
Germaine to the bill but the question
was raised by representative gon about
taking back a used Growler to the same
Brewery and what happens and I just
wanted to share from our experience
taking Growlers back to the same to the
original uh Brewery that we receive a
discount uh on the purchase of another
Growler so they take them back and they
sanitize them and they use them again
but they don't refill them thank
you um it was that a question to me Mr
chairman I think that was a would you
believe uh I would believe that I have
not personally experienced it at the
brewery's eye visit but I would believe
it the ones I've been to in New
Hampshire they all clean it right then
and there but but I have been to hker
and in uh
and he's got a whole wall full of
everybody else's uh Growlers up on the
wall
there but um I guess it's an interesting
Nuance to me the most they really want
you to come back and buy more of their
of their product they don't really want
you to go to take your your container
over to somebody else but but you're
asking for something really simple it
says uh why you know why refuse just
because it's somebody else's Growler you
can why shouldn't should the state stop
you from doing it but so it's an
interesting question you're posing but
um I would venture to say that that um I
would be very surprised there's a lot of
Brewers who think this is a great idea
but um I'll leave that you to to figure
that one out for us so but at this point
um that's where we're at all right no
more questions and we'll ask uh attorney
Moore for the Liquor Commission who is
neutral on this legislation and wants to
share
one minute of thoughtful information
well I'm afraid Mr chairman I may go
longer than that in light of
the you mean you falsify your uh well I
I I'm I'm going to try to
clarify um what uh is currently the law
and distinguish it from business
practices okay which are being exercised
by some businesses
um the the word Growler is not defined
anywhere in title 13 we were using that
as a light it's a it's a it's a it's a
slang term and I don't I don't mean that
in any type of disparaging way it's a
slang term that is used to describe a
refillable container that how the
industry views refilling uh a container
or filling a container with be Beverages
and beer
um Growlers are intended for personal
consumption they're not intended to be
commercially used so therefore a
consumer who goes to a a beverage
manufacturer decides they want to
purchase
a we'll call a growler um and uh it's to
consume at home or consume by themselves
or with friends or with wh whomever they
wish um there is nothing in the law that
forbids a consumer who bought a growler
at Brewery a from going to brewery B and
saying I have this container I'd like
you to fill it for me most likely if
it's being denied it's often on a
question of whether or not that Brewer
Brewer B feels this adequate quality
control over their product uh most
manufa facturers want to have their
products represented in the best
possible light um but there's nothing um
in RSA 175 colon
2 that
forbids a consumer from having their
Growler
filled at a beverage manufacturer who is
different from where they originally
made the
purchase
1752 is really focused at The Liquor
Commission
and it's te telling the commission that
they need to cause precautions to be
taken uh necessary to ensure the Purity
and freedom of
misbranding of Liquors sold and it
doesn't speak to beverages uh it doesn't
speak to wine so a person for example
who bought a gr you know let's say a
growler of wine uh who wanted to go to a
wine manufacturer's facility and have
that refilled could do that as well so
uh at the risk
of um trying to complicate the
conversation uh I'm I'm hoping to
provide some clarity which um and again
the the phrasing of Growler is really
based
upon um a term that's used in five uh
statutes uh 17821 20a 22 12a and 20 that
uses the phrase suitable
container
and the commission has historically
interpreted the word the phrase I should
say suitable
container as that which
is in the ABS of something more specific
that that is the language that the
commission has said would permit a
beverage
manufacturer uh
allowing uh them to refill a container
that is purchased by a consumer now um
I'm hoping I'm not going around in
circles on this and I'm gonna certainly
guess I may have some questions
but
um representative prout's bill I think
is does um I I really don't believe I
see a uh I don't want to say a need for
it I don't want to question the
motivation of it but I think the law as
it's currently written would permit a
consumer to go to a different Brewery
and have their Growler filled at that
other Brewery it would be the prob
probably if it were refused it would be
based upon the manufacturer's own
quality control standards that would
probably cause them not to refill
it and I'll be happy to take any
questions uh that's uh very
interesting I've seen this before I
remember years ago people always say
fireworks are illegal in New Hampshire
and they said that because they didn't
want us to have fireworks then we passed
it and then then hell Brook so sometimes
people will use the law to to their to
their advantage
but at
anyway uh I will I will let you uh weigh
in on uh again Andrew but I'm just
checking to see if anybody has any more
questions and I don't see any so uh
representative proud you want to wrap it
up with this new piece of
information thank you Mr chairman um
actually in light of that uh new piece
of information which is helpfully
memorialized on YouTube now uh I would
uh actually Pro probably agree that uh
considering that this is already not
illegal and that any claims otherwise
are do not align with the views of the
Liquor Commission uh I would not think
this bill would be
necessary fair enough thank you very
much and I I will go anybody in the
attendees who would like to weigh in
before we close out this public hearing
uh See n okay and I I keep forgetting to
do this but um terms of the the listing
in the bill we had uh we had 13
supporting it one
opposed who is cake fry from new
Futures
and uh and one neutral which is aen so
with that I will close the public
hearing on H Bill 403 and and bring up
our last public hearing for
today which
is um House Bill 245 rela to the
definition of grocery or convenience
store and representative abenson are you
back there you are okay so
representative abenson you can go ahead
and introduce your
bill am I allowed to go
early oh what time we have a I thought I
was behind oh you're right about that um
I don't I just don't remember what the
rules are when uh techically I guess I'm
supposed to wait yeah you're right I can
we can we can wait it's
fine so so everybody can take a 10
minute 10 minute break and we'll pick it
up at 3:15 I didn't realize we get
caught up so fast but
okay um Mr chairman I have a question
for you as long as we're in a
inter I'm looking ahead to tomorrow's
executive session yes and I'm wondering
about any amendments um that there may
be and the only bill that I can see I
personally am aware of an amendment for
is the first one which is House Bill
62 and I just wondered if what is um I
don't have that in front of me what what
is House Bill 62 is relative to to
continued in network access to certain
Health Care
[Music]
Providers representative Marsh and
he brought an amendment and sent it to
everyone and
so okay just so you know that's the only
amendment that I'm aware of I mean you
don't you know you need to know off the
top of your head but uh okay so if you
have that you have that Amendment then I
do okay so you can make sure that's
distri it to committee
members has but I can send it again if
you if you think that's a good
idea
okay and I will in the meantime I will
look over and see see where I'm at with
with that okay okay I'm gonna go look
for that right now S I guess I got I'll
send it out right now since there's
nothing I'm I've got time perfect thank
you you're
welcome
John yeah
um are all the amendments out supposed
to We were supposed to have all the
Amendments so
uh uh are you time out for tomorrow or
you T it well yeah but that would
include are we going to take up uh the
one we missed today because of a lack of
amendment um the way I've been told is
that you know that if we didn't take it
up we're g to I'm going to reschedule
that one
reschedule all right I'm just I'm just
wondering um I'm not sure which uh email
address I have is getting that
information some of it I'm getting in my
uh Gmail account and some is the
legislative uh I'm sending it to the
committee distribution list so that
would be my legislative or no it doesn't
matter whatever you have told the house
clerk um you want to use the house clerk
so if he went on to the legislative page
uh and looked himself up would he what
it is right if you look at your look at
your um profile under this standing
committee of Commerce
or you I can do it right now if you
like I
like okay yeah I just sent two
amendments to you
recently well I think I had a
conversation with you I preferred the
Gmail and and You' have been sending me
some things but I haven't seen anything
about the Amendments right I only am in
charge of the zoom um addresses as far
as any other legislative business you're
really supposed to use whatever you've
told the house clerk um you would like
to to have so it could be that that I
use the committee distribution list that
is set up by the house clerk I don't
have my own private one other than for
the zoom invitations that's a there's a
big asterisk for that but
uh you say on the Commerce Committee
there's a list yeah if you just go to
the Commerce Committee then go to
yourself yeah you looked at the our web
page Chris we've talked about this over
and over you gotta let the CL house
clerk know if you want a different email
address used okay all right all
right okay uh we'll open up the public
hearing yeah
House Bill
245 and here from the prime
sponsor did he walk
away he he did kind of he was there a
little while ago and then he seemed
exasperated and walked off so I I wonder
if
he forgot something or I I don't know
what happened but he was there he was
there yeah I thought I saw him there too
but
um
so given that I I'm I'm doing a lousy
job of timing out um exec sessions um I
for next week I've not uh put any exec
sessions I'm just want to get through
all the bills we'll have heard
everything that we're going to hear and
then starting after that we'll then have
it be a little more organized about our
exec session for
bills
so okay so uh we'll start with uh
representative abon and to introduce his
belt uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
members for of the committee for taking
my testimony that this is House Bill 245
uh can you guys see me with the lighting
I opened up all the windows and whatnot
so well that background is know okay I
I'll I'll I'll try looking for another
background after I introduce the bill um
this is a bill that's been introduced a
couple of times before and it it is Al
gets most of the Republicans on this
committee support but not all um
essentially House Bill 2 245 the the
convenience stores the wine and grocery
stores uh sorry the wine the beer wine
and tobacco stores have a requirement in
place that um was added some time ago
that simply says that if you're going to
sell beer wine that you have to also
sell 3,000
or you have to stock you don't have to
sell it um and the problem is that it
doesn't sell $3,000 worth of inventory
of grocery store like items um and the
Liquor Commission has um some uh
recommendations on that that those
businesses have to
follow and the problem with that is that
there's no possible way to make money
off that inventory so what virtually all
of these convenience stores have been
doing is just
buying Kansas spam theena sausage Chef
boy Rd um if you go into the ice box to
go grab a bag of ice you'll notice that
there's a frozen loaf of bread in there
that tells you that it's a New Hampshire
store as far as I know I I don't know of
another Northeastern State actually I
don't know of any other state that that
does something like this or takes it to
this level and I get asked questions a
lot when people are in the convenience
store they they'll ask just kind of
randomly or sporadically how come they
have an eight box of Cheerios just
sitting there and it's almost at its
expiration date and we have all this
other stuff in there and it's just a
state mandate that's been in place for
for a number of
years and the argument that I've gotten
from the that we've gotten from the
opponents on this effort to repeal this
unfunded
mandate
is more often than not that they would
like to send a message that they want
people eating food with beer or wine um
I don't disagree with the idea that
people should be eating food but the
kind of food that's being Stu is the
stuff that doesn't expire even after a
year it's sugary
starchy uh loaded with preservatives and
it's the the kind of stuff that I would
I would probably discourage people from
eating I'm not a professional
nutritionist but uh when I'm eating
healthy
um the last place I'm going to go and
pick up food is the convenience store
understand they have lots of bags of
chips but they also have to stock up on
all sorts of canned items um boxes of
Hamburger Helper that have been sitting
there for a year boxes of cereal that
have been sitting there for a year uh of
course the Frozen loaf of bread that's
been sitting in the ice box for a year
the fact that these cans and boxes are
just sitting there accumulating you know
more and more dust
um contributes to a lot of other health
issues um including the accumulation of
fungus bacteria viruses and who El who
knows what um what's on them food is not
supposed to sit in inventory for long
periods of time and and to argue that
this is a healthier way um I think what
happened in the last hearing uh maybe
chairman hunt can remember but I think
they finally conceded that that they
didn't necessarily want people eating
this food but they wanted to send a
message to people who are consuming
alcohol that they wanted them to eat
food with their 30 pack of PS Blue
Ribbon or whatever they're going to
whatever they're going to have I don't I
don't I'm not sure that adding more
calories to an unhealthy diet um of
alcohol is is necessarily helping
anyone
um the the other concern is that when I
see the look on people's faces it seems
to break down their sense of respect for
the rule of law that our job as
legislators is to add modify and also
repeal outdated laws or laws that don't
make any sense and when they see that
there are laws in place requiring that
stores stock up on Things That No One
buys it's so dubious it's so
questionable that it it it kind of
destroys people's faith in the in the
Democratic
process that if there's no apparent
reason or if the reason is really
complicated or if the reason seems to be
cronyism or protectionism that there's
some established business over here
lobbying to protect themselves from
competition it even appears that way it
it breaks down people's faith in the
process and it and it tends to break it
down from a pretty young
age um I've
um I have been working for years part of
New Hampshire's dumus law and other
efforts to repeal old outdated and
ridiculous laws that don't make any
sense um but that are not enforced but
this one is enforced and when we talk to
store owners um when they have their
smaller convenience stores they'd like
to be able to sell more beer wine and
tobacco products more specialized
products that can attract people from
the New England Market um we do compete
with uh stores that are in six other
states Northeastern states and people do
make the drive up to New Hampshire to
stock up I I live on the border and so I
see it all the time I see out ofate
plates here all the time as people come
in to do their shopping I think it's 40
or 45% of all retail sales in New
Hampshire are from out ofate
Shoppers and half of the New Hampshire
Advantage is the lower taxes but the
other half is that we're kind of the
live for your die state that we don't
have all the restrictions uh and
limitations that a lot of other states
have that that we don't kind of cut
people off um we don't try to regulate
business to death we don't try to ban
things to death so this isn't um by
opening up this part of the
marketplace um to allow these small
grossers to carry more specialized items
and more New Hampshire made items and
more of the um more of the products of
Nano Brewery there's a lot of innovation
going on right now in vaping and in
micro Brews and anal breweries and I
think that passing a bill like this and
repealing this replacing $33,000 worth
of Dusty Kansas fam replacing that with
actual New Hampshire made inventory I
think would be uh much much better of
course I am open to to Amendment um if
members have uh um ideas I'd like to get
that in today or tomorrow so um
but uh I've always thought that it it
made sense for convenience stores maybe
to hand handle a few hundred dollars
worth of emergency flares and emergency
supplies and first aid kits and things
like that the type of inventory you need
in a power outage or a car crash or some
other type of emergency that's always
made more sense to me rather than you
know $33,000 worth
of food that's not going to get
sold and I'll take questions
okay we do have questions uh
representative burrow is
first yes thanks for taking my question
and um my question is might I mean I
think a lot of what you're saying makes
sense but my question is might this bill
be a workaround for a convenience store
which is by definition a store that
sells also sells food to become a liquor
store no they're not allowed to sell
liquor um they are allowed to sell beer
and wine and tobacco products uh of
course um the the the question that
we're kind of asking or the question
we're kind of answering is uh what do
you do with this 15 square feet or so of
space is it going to be $3,000 worth of
food that doesn't buy or sell or is it
going to be $3,000 worth of you know
something from a micro brewery beer
products beer and wine products um
convenient stores aren't allowed to sell
liquor and
is thank you okay uh representative V
outon thank you very much and thank you
representative um I'm not sure that I
that I buy your classification of
convenience stores or of this type of
store because they can just be that
convenience stores a place to which a
family without transportation or a lot
of money can walk to buy the the daily
Essentials that they have um what makes
you think though that the New Hampshire
made item items would sell better in a
store that tends to be a corner store uh
that's that's available mostly to people
without major sources of income uh who
use the corner store to pick things up
on maybe a daily or weekly basis and
don't go for a major shopping and for a
healthier shopping I hope I didn't get
too intricate there I
apologize so the definition I should
have mentioned this earlier is it's RSA
175 Section 1 part 36 which is just
quote unquote grocery or convenience
store unquote means any retail
establishment where groceries are
regularly and customarily sold for
consumption off
premises um I believe in letting the
marketplace work that it makes sense to
let the suppliers Supply what people are
actually buying um I do live close to
about six of these small groceries or
Convenience Stores um and I do walk to
them about once a day um because it
saves me having to start up the car and
and you know deise the windows and
everything so that's a convenience for
me but it it's also a convenience to be
able to go go down to the convenience
store and pick things up but with six
grocery stores nearby obviously one of
them is you know about 30,000 square
feet and it has lots of of grocery items
why should the other five also have to
stock Things That No One buys or very
very few people buy if somebody somebody
who lives in my area um in Seabrook
wants to just walk somewhere or their
car isn't working um they'll go to the
big grow they'll go to the big one uh
the one that's right on the border um
because it is about 30,000 square feet
it's a it's a it's a really good siiz
facility we actually have several very
large um you know wine and tobacco
stores wine and beer stores in New
Hampshire in Seabrook that also have lot
lots and lots of this kind of inventory
um some that even compete with with uh
grocery stores as far as snack food
items are
concerned but it it doesn't make sense
to mandate to push a top down one size
fits-all mandate on every kind of store
when you've got most convenience stores
in the state have at least one or two
other convenient stores nearby it
doesn't make sense to try to turn them
all into small Grocers if if that's not
what the the Market's calling
for followup please other question may
inquire thank you uh and while that may
be true in your area along the border
and and to a great degree in my area
here in Manchester um is it possible
that the convenience stores give a
greater service to those people in the
further northern areas of our state
thank you actually used to live um yeah
I used to live uh
in I thinking Deerfield and there was a
a convenience store and because they
were just kind of the one store in town
um or the one store that was in walking
distance they stocked a lot of extra
food items but none of the fresh food
hot food items that they were selling
counted towards this $3,000 requirement
so in their case they had
to um set aside some of the space that
might have been used for food products
that people actually buy in order to
stock up
$3,000 of this kind of um
wholesale um Dusty cans of spam Dusty
cans of Vienna sausage $8 box of
Cheerios and so forth it it makes sense
just to let businesses Supply what
consumers are actually buying and not
make them stock up on material that
people do not buy thank
you uh representative
Belo thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question is the intent of this
bill um to create beer and wine stores
you referred to beer and wine stores
earlier could you explain why you called
beer and wine store the same thing as a
convenience
store um the statute calls them grocery
or convenience store and that's the
license that they get um that's the
license that the state issues for them
um but they primarily sell beer wine
tobacco uh some of them sell a lot of
other items like big gos nachos hot dogs
and that kind of thing but they they
have to adapt to kind of what's there in
the market the buyers versus the
competitors that they have um
so some of them in order to compete they
know that they're competing in the whole
New England Marketplace not just in
their particular Town most the
convenience store purchases are actually
from people out of town and a lot of
them on the on the border where I am are
from m state so they need in those cases
in those exceptional cases they need to
be able to stock up on uh specialized
tobacco products specialized vaping
products
specialized you know wines that are
being made in New Hampshire beers that
are being made in New Hampshire um or in
the New England Market that are that are
that are different where they can
attract buyers to those stores um and
you can't do that if you're if you're
you know have two aisles that are
dedicated to just complying with the
state mandate and um people go according
to some of the cash register employees
will go you know a couple of weeks
without a single sale from either of
those
aisles follow up Mr chair there the
question being
inquire um you called this an unfunded
mandate could you explain that it's a
mandate and there's not a single Dollar
in funding going down to any of these
stores they're just they lose sales um
the only thing that they save money on
is business taxes 70% of state revenue
comes from from business taxes so this
is really our our tax base that we're
talking about um an unfunded mandate
means that the store owner has to pay
for it to hold all this inventory that
doesn't move and the state doesn't
compensate them in any way except that
of course with the business profits tax
if you're profits are lower you're
paying less money to the state and
business profits tax but that causes a a
revenue shortfall for us up
here all right thank
you okay uh any more questions
for represent Aon seeing none uh okay
attorney Moore uh who is
neutral thank you Mr chairman
um just so that uh the committee is
aware every licensed type in the state
of New Hampshire regardless of what type
that is has as a part of it a
prerequisite
qualifying uh condition or conditions so
for example if I want to be uh a
restaurant uh I have to have food
available and um I may not want food
available but that's what I've been told
uh is the requirement for me to be
eligible to hold the license type that
we have the same exists for convenience
stores and grocery stores they are
convenience stores the the intent is to
really um the legislature has in the
past put uh in place a definition that
says this is the type of products that
you should have that they believe to be
items that are of a convenience um and
that
the businesses are you know if there are
six businesses just as an example in the
same area competing um they're all
competing at the same on the same
footing uh not one has an advantage over
the other except for maybe their
location and their
pricing um so we feel that the system as
it exists based upon its uh
being a definitional based
system U works and if the requirement
for um carrying con uh convenience items
food regularly commonly sound sold
grocery products excuse me um then there
is no threshold other than to have four
walls and now anybody can open a a beer
store if they wish um and
I'm not sure that how that would work
necessarily with for example um local
zoning and some of the things that would
be part of um the local consideration
and permitting process uh but the we've
not heard any complaints from anyone uh
over the years from any L that I've ever
had an experience with who said I I
don't have enough shelf space for my
beer I need more shelf space
they have what they have and if they
sell all that they have they can get
more deliveries and sell more and uh so
the system that we have is is really one
um that is consistent with every other
aspect of title 13 and how licenses are
issued and uh changing them changing
this particular segment of the market
where there are I believe over
1,400 licenses
then that is going to have a pretty
significant uh possible impact now I I
don't believe that there this change
would prohibit anyone from bringing in
groceries they'd bring in what they
wanted but um it would change the
threshold for eligibility and that would
be a pretty significant change within
title
13 and I'll be happy to take any
questions great uh representative Abel
has a
question yes thank you um um Mr MOA am I
am I correct that if a store chose not
to sell beer or wine that they would not
need to get a license and they could
sell anything else that they wanted this
is only only to get a a license to sell
those that that this requirement
exists uh thank you for your question
representative yes convenience stores
are uh there I mean there are some that
exist that don't sell beer and wine but
uh this is the eligibility piece that uh
is put in place to be able to sell beer
and wine under the provisions of uh RSA
um
18 so um that's where the linkage is the
definition of that is before you is is
linked to the requirements in rsa1 78
178 col 18 the combination
license well Set uh representative
Herbert thank you chairman
hunt um and thank you Mr Moore for
taking my
question
if if this uh this hurdle uh for uh
things other than alcohol
are uh was was to be
eliminated and if that meant all they
carry were like package stores except
it's just beer and wine would that
increase the
profits for the state more than the
existing
setup uh thank you for your question uh
I I don't know the answer to that I
don't we've not been asked to provide uh
anytime of fiscal uh worksheet
associated with this
bill the
um I
think I think business people if feel if
they felt that there was an
opportunity uh to make money they would
locate themselves in a position you know
as uh representative abson describes in
seab Brook there are maybe six stores
within close proximity to one another
I'm sure each of those owners felt
it's worth my time even though there's
competition right down the street it's
worth my time I can get my market share
by locating here they've made a a
conscious business decision to move uh
forward in that
regard if this requirement were
removed um my guess is that anyone who
can get themselves four walls will be
applying for a license to sell beer and
wine um knowing that the only thing they
have to have is four walls and it it is
a pretty significant
change that will have the impact of
Greater sales certainly you'll probably
see um initially people uh getting into
the marketplace they'll be strict
competition and eventually some of these
businesses that jump in are going to
fail because it's going to be who can
provide the lowest price and um of of
course that leads to the potential of
Greater opportunity for underage
drinking and underage
access uh so I I can I can see those
types of uh issues I can't necessarily
predict with any certainty sir what type
of additional Revenue might be produced
by this type of change just one further
observation or question further question
may inquire it would seem to me uh and
and I I want your opinion on this that
if you ended up with
uh six stores now they're all selling
nothing but beer and wine that there
would open up a market for an actual
grocery
store uh so I think the market would
adjust I'm just I'm I'm not a big guy
having a I'm not in favor of having a
package store on every
corner but uh I know in Manchester uh we
almost do have that and uh a lot of
stores are got very little in the way of
food stuffs and a lot in the way of
cigarettes and beer and uh and wine so I
have I um I'm
not I think what do you think the market
would
do other than this first part you said
well well they'll all be selling the
same stuff and they'll be you know going
out of business because they can't get a
margin but what would happen on the
other side of the uh of the supermarket
aisle
um it occurs to me that there might be
the problem might be that they shouldn't
be competing with beer and wine and that
there should be stores that are small
but they're grocery stores we do have a
few of those in Manchester too so where
we go with this Chris I just I was just
waned to know if you had an opinion on
uh what the market might look like in a
year if we actually pass
this um I really am not in a position
great yeah that's I'm really not in
position to answer that sir um yeah okay
thank you though thank you for thank you
for the question all right
representative Weston thank you chairman
hunt and thank you for taking my
question um representative aberson
mentioned that hot food was not included
in the $3,000 figure I'm wondering why
it's not included and if there any other
exemptions the def definition of of
um
1751 Roman 36 speaks to the types of
things that they would want an eligible
ly to hold um first it's a wholesale
value not retail
value um and it's $3,000 worth of
commonly found grocery products not
including cigarettes magazines
newspapers wine or
beverages the
production of uh the uh many many stores
for example um these days you may find
some of them that have a uh they're a
convenience store I'll think of you know
I have a son at UNH I go up there uh to
visit him and there's a convenience
store there that Irving which has uh
many many grocery items uh and also
within it has a Dunkin Donuts or it has
hot dogs or
hamburgers um
the application is if it's I think the
way we've interpreted it and applied it
is that if it's subject to a rooms and
meals
tax then we don't count it because it's
it's coming in U and being uh taxed in
that regard so it's it's a different
category of
food well I don't understand that
question what do you mean you don't
count it wouldn't anything that's going
to be collected as rooms and meals is
well if if if we were I mean if if
someone um I'll try to use an example to
see if I can Illustrated if if someone
has in their uh facility a cooler and
the cooler has hot
dogs um those would those would count
the owner of the store may take the hot
dogs out of the cooler and then put them
in the steamer and then sell them at
retail um and those are subject to
taxations but as long as they're
available to the consumer as a grocery
item they would
count I'm not sure if I've answered your
question representative or no you
answered it perfectly
I okay representative ham you're
next now you're B you're
muted I'm sorry representative I cannot
hear you okay
um thank you Mr chairman I'm I'm just
trying to um figure this out uh $3,000
isn't a lot of groceries that's not very
many at all and so that you know isn't
too onerous for somebody to have $3,000
worth of food and I don't know whether
beverages include um whether in food you
can include uh you know the mixers the
Coke and the ginger ale and and the
orange juice and all that that would all
count that would all count that would
that would count as groceries yes ma'am
okay so it's very easy $3,000 isn't much
of a bar to um to meet um it's hardly
any groceries at all and um you could
have uh you you could be a major um have
every kind of specialty beer which isn't
necessarily bad which is is very much uh
What uh tourists and people coming to
enjoy themselves anywhere in the state
um they love it when they can go into a
store and see a a vast
array and variety of beers so and would
that be is that would be perfectly legal
and be a convenience or a grocery store
if you had $3,000 and that like I said
$3,000 doesn't go very far that's a real
small number
would that be qualify as a a conven
convenience or grocery store if you had
$3,000 worth of groceries and $200,000
worth of
beer well uh thank you for your question
representative uh the legislature has
created a uh a creature called a beer
specialty license and the beer specialty
license um is a license that's a
different license Li than the one that
we're speaking of for
17818 this particular license falls
under
17819 hyphen D is in David and as a
requirement that El for
eligibility that business must have uh
an inventory of 500 or more selected
beer
labels and they too have a requirement
for uh food uh and non-alcoholic
beverages uh excuse me food which has a
wholesale value of not less than
$1,000 so from a policy standpoint I
think the legislature has said if you're
putting your money into inventory that
amounts to 500 distinct labels then
we're not going to relieve you of your
requirement for food we're just going to
reduce the amount that you need to carry
to be eligible to hold a license and in
this particular
case translate that into the combination
license the legislature has said you can
sell as much beer as you want you don't
have to have a certain number you can
have just one label if you want but to
be eligible to sell as a combination
license to sell beer and wine unlike the
beer specialty store which sells only
beer beer and wine you have to have the
$3,000 worth of commonly found grocery
products I hope I've answered your
question yes yes thank you I just find
it not an honorous amount of food to
have in order to become a would you
believe become a a specialty place um
I'm not saying it's wrong I'm not saying
I'm against it but I wouldn't see the
$3,000 being a barrier thank you okay uh
representative
Ammon
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony um attorney Moore I'm
just curious about the enforcement of
the $3,000 requirement you said it's
wholesale value yes uh does someone come
around with a calculator and a clipboard
and make sure that it adds up to at
least $3,000 um how is this
enforced thank you uh thank you for your
question representative uh the first
place it would be uh you you'd encounter
this would be at the time of initial
licensing uh we would go in um and ask
the applicant uh because this is a
condition of their license to provide us
with copies of or to show us invoices
that show that they have uh met the
prerequisite $3,000 in a wholesale
figure um once that has occurred and the
license is issued uh then the uh uh lcy
would be subject to regular
inspection and if that figure were to
drop or if the if the uh
investigator suspected that the
inventory had uh lapsed
significantly would probably uh let the
lensy know that this they were going to
come back for an audit and they would
look at then monitoring what was on the
shelves what was available to the public
and if it was below the
$3,000 uh certainly they would ask the
licensing to get into compliance please
you know this is a requirement of your
license uh please get the levels up to
where they need to go um over my career
with liquor enforcement um I encountered
that many many times uh the goal was
always to get the licensing in
compliance uh not to put them out of
business and um most of them were more
than willing to try to make sure that
they complied with the law uh for those
who just didn't care they said you know
I got my license and uh I'll do what I
want to do well then there are other
remedies available uh for those in
non-compliance as well so the initial
determination is made at at lure initial
lure and then during reg regular uh
follow-up inspections if there's a
question then they would ask the license
he to be participating in inventory to
try to bring them into compliance
followup question further question what
what would you estimate uh the
enforcement uh costs as far as uh
resources
and uh
Personnel uh to enforce this particular
provision I I think it's part of the
regular budget um Chief armaganian and
his staff provide routine inspections
throughout the year um their their plan
is to certainly visit um every ly at
least once and to ensure that the
Integrity of the licensing system uh
remains so I I can't give you a specific
cost on what one inspection might cost
but I can certainly tell you that it's
part of the regular enforcement duties
carried out by uh that
division okay thank you
representative
gson thank you Mr Moore for answering
our questions today uh is a store that
primarily sells grocery items required
to stock $3,000 worth of alcohol and
cigarettes and if not why do we require
a store that primarily sells alcohol and
cigarettes to stock $3,000 worth of
food um
I'm G see if I can understand your
question representative thank you um
there there is no requirement for for
the ly to carry a certain amount of
alcohol they they carry what their what
their store can support in the way of uh
space and what their consumers want so
if you're um if you're on a a border uh
you will carry what you believe the
people who come across the border want
um
keeping in mind that there are also um
state liquor stores that are in that
vicinity who also are selling alcohol
and so therefore your pricing is not
going to be maybe as competitive as it
would be with the state certainly but
you're offering convenience somebody
wants to come in so we we don't um
mandate what quantity of alcohol or what
types of alcohol a license he carry it's
up to them uh but we try to make sure
that the system all of the licensing
systems that we administer um that are
handed to us are are uniformly
applied followup sir a question inquire
y did you not just make representative
abramson's case
exactly to the tea of why we don't need
$3,000 worth of food in a store that
sells beer wine because there are other
places in town that sell the food at a
much cheaper price not eight for a box
of cereal Etc and I you just exactly
laid it out and I don't even consume
alcohol so please don't misunderstand I
have no dog in this in this
race that's so would you
believe would you believe would you
believe uh thank you for your question
representative I I don't believe I've
made representative abramson's case um I
I think what I have tried to lay out for
you is that the eligibility eligibility
for lure uh exists across the board
across the state so whether you're up in
Pittsburgh New Hampshire or CBR New
Hampshire if you hold a license under
17818 uh to be eligible you are expected
to have $3,000 worth of commonly found
grocery products at the time of lure and
to maintain that during your licensing
period you and your wish to change that
policy that's
certainly
okay uh
so assume Keith you and Jeff you're all
set so you can put your hands down
unless you still have another question
or something we're all set all right uh
we thank you very much jorney more uh so
what do I have next here is uh Keith
Kevin
dangle so
Kevin oh um oh I see the chief enforcer
wants to speak but let's let Kevin Kevin
go and then and then then I'll have the
chief because he Tech Kevin just there
he is down
there don't do that to me don't move
around when you have your hand up leave
it
up
okay
okay Kevin dagel who newshire groceries
Association there's John Dumis and uh
posed and would like to take five
minutes go ahead Kevin great thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee uh
yes you're right John isn't here today
um for the record I'm Kevin dagel vice
president of the New Hampshire Grocers
Association uh many of you may be
familiar with who we are uh for those
that aren't um the New Hampshire
groceries Association represents grocery
stores convenience stores wholesalers
Distributors all operating here in New
Hampshire these include the small
independent mom and pop operators as
well as the large chain operated groups
um we appear here today we have some
concerns with this bill eliminating the
inventory required by Grocery and
convenience stores therefore as you
mentioned chairman uh we are here today
in opposition to this bill um our
association and its members realize the
serious nature of selling baren wine and
the impact that can have on individuals
and the community at large Grocers have
always supported the concept that these
products are better utilized as part of
a meal rather than being promoted as a
sole item to consume that's why you see
restaurants and food stores regularly
promoting pairings when they offer these
items for sale um the requirement of
having a minimum inventory of consumable
food products in order to sell beer and
wine addresses just that important
concept it encourages the responsible
consumption of alcohol alol that does
does not exist in other states which
allow simply package stores the
association of having food with any
alcoholic beverage discourages the
notion of binge drinking in addition
retail establishments where alcohol is a
sole product each sale becomes more
important and could lead to Greater
liquor enforcement
violations today as uh Aiden Moore had
mentioned there are approximately 1,400
off- premise licenses in the state these
are essentially your growth Grocery and
convenience stores a substantial
majority of these are the small
independent mom and pop type retailers
many of them dependent upon a few
categories to draw their customers to
the stores these stores understand the
impact that alcohol can have on their
survival and go to Great Lengths to
ensure that only legal sales are
made we as an association have always
defended having grocery inventory as a
requirement to sell be wine back in the
70s we even supported legislation
provided that the groceries were a mix
of common food items this was done to
ensure that you do not buy only
expensive items and leave them on the
Shelf your Kansas bam your Vienna
sausage um thus circumventing the law
and becoming a pseudo package store this
also helps out consumers in the small
rural towns who may have limited access
to retail stores and even worse limited
Transportation this allows those
consumers to know they'll have a place
to get necessary items when needed um I
made a couple of notes when
representative Abramson was talking um
in regards to having room for New
Hampshire made
items there's nothing stopping these
businesses now from stocking and selling
New Hampshire made items there are
plenty of them that are consumable
plenty of them that would fall within
those parameters um in regards to Dusty
cansas spam in Vienna sausages um you
know Common business practice goes to
say you know if stocking these items
aren't moving then you know we should
reevaluate what we sell and have an
inventory and stock those items whether
we differentiate ourselves from our
competitor that's right down the street
or the five competitors surrounding us
or we're the only one if an item's not
moving gets
re-evaluated um reassessed and then we
stock items that we think will move in
closing the current statute has a very
practical purpose and should not be
eliminated by this bill because of this
we hope that you find this bill
inexpedient to legislate thank you
I'll feeli any questions uh
representative burough has a question
sure yes thanks for taking my question
um I understand what you're saying about
um encouraging people to eat food while
you know when they buy alcohol it's
better to do that than to to drink
without food but wouldn't that also be
an argument for dismantling New
Hampshire liquor stores that don't sell
food that's not my purvey that would be
another bill to get Spirits into grocery
stores right represent
pun well they've already with some
controversy they've already expanded by
adding adding uh the
non-alcoholic uh mixers and things like
that that they have held off for a very
long time
right so uh representative
Abel thank you uh thank you um and thank
you Mr dagel for for your testimony um
when uh issue similar to this bills
similar to this have come up in the last
several uh sessions um I recall that uh
there was argu there was argument given
that
um that there are food deserts in in New
Hampshire as there are everywhere else
both in urban areas and in rural areas
and that some people had a fear that
that uh stores in in such places would
stop selling food because they could
make more money selling selling beer and
wine and this was a a an ATT one reason
why we wanted to encourage those stores
to continue to sell food am I right or
wrong in In My Memory no you are
absolutely correct representative and in
great great question um there are food
deserts U mainly up north um Northwest
areas of the state um the concerns come
even foremost with uh those that are on
uh assistance whether it's you know EBT
funds or or Wick type funding um being
in those areas where there's only one
local store um eliminating that need to
have you know a grocery inventory though
they may seem that they have the
clientele there you're right um they may
just become a package store um now
leaving these folks without access to to
nutrients great question thank you all
right seeing no more questions thank you
very much for your testimony I would say
Kevin you got to fix your microphone or
something because it was really scratchy
something going on with that mic I
appreciate that thank you I'll do that
check on that okay uh so uh Chief arning
did did you want to U give us some
information about this so far where
we're at uh thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you again uh again Mark
armaganian chief of liquor enforcement
and Licensing um first of all Kevin uh
literally I hate to say stole a lot of
my what I was going to say um one thing
that I think those of you that have been
around and and heard me testify not only
at this job but uh at my State Police
position prior to this uh my platform
has always been Community safety and
keeping your community sa um the pairing
of food requirement and alcohol has
always been Nationwide has been a
industry standard um does the dollar
amount move yeah the dollar amount does
move and that requirement moves a little
bit but the standard of having
with whether we're talking um restaurant
or cocktail lounge um or um or a
combination license such as this um that
food requirement is is literally about
keeping your community safe and and
offsetting um the the consumption of
alcohol with with a salad with
food um it and there was a a
a statement made
about um compliance earlier um I I
representative am was at you um as far
as holding licensing accountable I know
you and I have been trying to your
invent do your
audits okay I asked about okay um I I
could uh tell you this I don't know
everybody's uh contact with with liquor
enforcement in previous administrations
I know uh aen Moore former Chief um uh
can speak very well about his
administration but this Administration
is all about making sure that number one
your leny is educated and our consumers
and our servers are
educated um we're not coming in like the
big bad wolf and hanging for a lack of a
better term hanging paper on everybody
um whether it's covid times or any other
times it's literally just trying to get
them into compliance just again with
that that overtone of safety um and that
is a yeah Aiden did a very good job um
uh talking about
compliance um and and we have Auditors
that actually civilian Auditors that go
out uh representative so uh we're not
paying we're being fiscally responsible
and not paying the money of an
investigator when a civilian auditor can
go out and do the same job and if there
is a administrative action I could tell
you that Administration is way down the
road um because we give I hate to give
the answers to the test but we give a
wide birth here uh to those
lenses and everybody did a great job
testifying I just needed to say that I
know it's been a long day but your
questions have been awesome and and
uh the the testifying that has been
going on I've been sitting on the
sidelines here
listening everybody's taken a a concern
effort and and all the bills that have
come before you and I can't tell you how
much I as the head of this agency
appreciate that because it's obvious it
means something
for thank you unless there are any
questions I'll answer any
questions so Chief I have a question and
I guess I should know this answer but I
don't know it just kind of dawned on me
um because I had forgotten that we that
anything that collected rooms and meals
is uh not considered
groceries and if if our public policy is
that we really want people to be eating
something wouldn't make sense for us to
uh bring in you know that that if they
did have sandwiches pre-made sandwiches
and if they did have you know the hot
dogs and the burritos I think I've had a
burrito that if if they wouldn't that be
good that that that be considered part
of a food because we certainly think
that's good enough for restaurants you
know restaurants so just plain Devils
Havoc here but shouldn't I'm not sure
could other Foods replace that might
better fulfill this this um this action
yeah absolutely I mean you you have the
there are seven and I um put myself on
the spot between cereals Dairy
Meats uh breads snack foods vegetables
fruits those are all part of uh I think
it's liquor rule 404 I'm going say 2ish
around there but it actually stipulates
out what those requirements are those
categories are that you need to have
food in um but could that alter to the
times absolutely it's some something
that is uh easily consumable on the spot
really does fulfill fulfill that need uh
probably I would argue more so than
something you had to CAU exactly exactly
and that and was funny because when
representative Herber says well what's
the revenue loss and I was thinking well
rooms and meals but if rooms and meals
was never really included food um but
what's more important to me is I I think
the his history is that um at the time
when we decided that we really did want
to have beer and it wasn't wine it was
just beer and we wanted we didn't want
to have packies we didn't want to have
somebody who solely sold beer and so we
made the decision that we would give it
to the convenience stores and then we
had to to find who was what was a
convenience store and at that time that
was you know those were the igas those
little Community igas which I'm old
enough to remember I don't know most
everybody here knows remembers igas but
but um that that now when we really
think about it if we want to make the
case that it's about food we want them
to eat something or something we really
would rather have them eating something
that they'll could act eat right away
rather than have to take it home and and
make it or bake it or whatever they have
to do with which was what our food
requirement is now AB absolutely Mr
chairman very good point you need to fix
your sound your sound was crappy sorry
do I need to move closer closer sounds
better yeah all of a sudden it was
really iy or something some say I talk
too much so that might be a good thing I
would to that okay any other questions
for uh Chief harag seeing none we thank
you very much thank you not least Kate I
just I wanted you to be the icing on the
cake Kate and uh and uh and and feel
free to tell us why you're opposed to
everything else that you didn't testify
for um yeah I just signed in on bills
that I didn't want to take the
committee's time I am test on bills that
we feel strongly that we need to um
oppose and House Bill 245 is one of them
um thank you members of the committee
I'll be as brief as I can and we'll try
not to repeat because I know you've had
a long day um we oppose this bill for
many of the reasons that were cited
today by The Liquor Commission and the
Grocers Association I think it's
important to remember and I appreciate
um the chief's um history and actually
representative hunt what he mentioned
about the purp of the current grocery
requirement was really uh important to
both public health and safety and
Community reputation and ensure that
communities aren't burdened by a
proliferation of package stores um that
sells nothing but alcohol and tobacco
products um so if this bill were to pass
Our concern would be an increase of
alcohol outlets and high alcohol Outlet
density defined as a high concentration
of retail alcohol outlets in a small
area it can be environmental risk
factors for excessive drinking we also
know it's associated with many social
harms among neighborhoods in and around
the alcohol Outlet area such as
disorderly conduct noise violence public
nuisance and we also know low-income
minority communities often have a higher
density of alcohol Outlets than um
wealthier communities um and then
therefore are kind of living within that
um disproportionate access um and the
harms that come out of that um so I
think it's just really important to to
stress that as well too um we seek to
improve racial Health disparities among
the marginalized groups but also ensure
that all graned Staters are healthy now
and into the future and so we really
look at this as an important component
of Public Health and um we would ask the
committee to it
it fair enough there any questions from
the committee
oh I'm sorry can I say one more thing
representative of course I did just want
to uh definitely underscore what
representative AEL said too as well as
the concern around creating food deserts
in some of these um communities as
well fair enough okay uh there any
questions from the committee members
seeing none we thank you all very much
uh Republicans will remind you that we
have a caucus at 5:30 and we'll get to
do this all over again tomorrow at nine
o'clock oh I speaking this bill 245 it
had the three three supporters and five
opposed um who were they're all mixed
group and mutual so with that we'll
close the public hearing and we'll talk
to you all tomorrow take care hey John
yes a question